mobile task force Edna 84 also known by
the code name and thus upon his Crucible
is on one of the strangest missions
they've ever been sent on they sit in a
darkened room beads of sweat trickling
down their brows the lights of computer
monitors shine upon their faces they're
tackling a monster that if it escapes
will literally devour all of creation it
has no fear it has no remorse and if it
isn't kept contained by Edna 84 it may
escape and wreak havoc across the world
oh and did we mention it's trapped in a
Minecraft server you heard us right
scp-4335 is a Cognito hazardous
extra-dimensional being of pure Terror
trapped inside a procedurally generated
world in the immensely popular game
Minecraft you hear about a lot of
horrifying monsters being described as
lovecraftian but only this monster is
Minecraft in there's a lot that needs
explaining here and we intend to get to
all of it but let's start with how the
foundation keeps This truly exceptional
Beast contained the foundation first
discovered
scp-4335 back in 2010 shortly after the
Alpha version of Minecraft was released
because of the online nature of the game
it's proven to be impossible to contain
4335 externally seeing as it isn't
confined to any one physical location
shutting off the server 4335 is found in
is not an effective containment method
either as this just causes the entity to
Simply hop to a different server the
foundation's greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of
Minecraft and cause chaos in our world
that's why it's imperative to draft
containment procedures for
scp-4335 within the game this led to the
creation of a containment site unlike
any other site M1 the first official
Foundation site made entirely out of
Minecraft blocks everyone who was
originally involved in the server has
been removed and anistatized since then
a lead SCP Foundation containment
Specialists and Gamers have been
constructing the perfect prison for
scp-4335 side M1 is a large Stone
complex built into the side of a
mountain it has a number of key features
including a supply area filled with
materials vital for 4335's continued
containment chests filled with books
that contain
scp-4335's containment procedures a few
animal farms for the purpose of breeding
and killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about 4335 if
they ever breach containment and enter
the server and of course the actual
containment chamber for
scp-4335 itself which is a little more
complicated
4335's containment chamber is built out
of several layers all made from iron
blocks the outermost cube is 75 by 75 by
75 blocks the inner cube is 55 by 55 by
55 blocks and the innermost cube is 25
by 25 by 25 blocks creating several
levels of Defense finally one layer
within all these others which contains
the anomaly proper is made from obsidian
blocks
scp-4335 is bound into the center of the
containment chamber with a complex
mechanism the outermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time line the cube the cube also
contains several mob Farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to
scp-4335 there are even contingency
measures for if
scp-4335 manages to breach in
containment if Escape is attempted
blocks of TNT detonate above the ceiling
causing lava to pour into the chamber at
that point MTF Edna 84 are dispatched
into the server to lure 4335 back into
its containment chamber to do this they
fire a mix of fire resistant potions and
ender pearls which have teleportation
capabilities interestingly there's one
more basic method of luring
scp-4335 back into the obsidian Cube
taunting and insulting one of
scp-4335's many anomalous abilities is
being able to hear people through the
screen and being a proud creature it
often responds to insults by charging in
to directly Engage The insulter if
scp-4335 still manages to breach the
containment that has been set up for it
then they even expect that it will
likely soon hop into another server at
that point the goal will shift to
finding the monster and re-containing it
with containment procedures this complex
and extensive it shouldn't come as a
surprise that
scp-4335 rests firmly in the ketter
class what exactly is this anomalous
entity why does its containment hinge on
constantly providing it with items and
how did it end up in Mojang's popular
building and survival game in the first
place
scp-4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4335 has been compared
to two popular Creepypasta figures
Herobrine and the Slenderman but 4335 is
far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the
game with a few peculiar anomalous
abilities we'll discuss soon handling
scp-4335 is an extremely delicate
process us if command blocks creative
mode or server commands are ever enabled
in a server with
scp-4335 the server will instantly shut
down and
scp-4335 will move to a different server
scp-4335 also uses its tendrils to
destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption
scp-4335 grows and when it reaches
sufficient size it hops to a different
server as you can see keeping
scp-4335 contained is an uphill battle
but luckily there are two factors on the
foundation side here the first is that
scp-4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to
actively Escape Foundation forces the
second factor is that
scp-4335 needs a rest period between
consuming blocks in order to grow
meaning if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn't able to grow
these two factors have informed the
entirety of the foundation's containment
procedures around
scp-4335 it's locked into its chamber
and fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when
scp-4335 begins to grow the foundation
also found that the application of Ender
Pearls helps reduce it back to its
normal size however
scp-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors 4335 is a
virgin class multi-sensory Cognito
Hazard anyone viewing it without proper
training and protection may experience
distressing hallucinations
scp-4335 is also capable of telepathic
speech with people playing on its server
and as we alluded to earlier it can also
hear any noises you make while playing
weird is a term thrown around a lot when
it comes to scps considering it's pretty
much a requirement for the foundation to
take interest in you but the null
devouring Minecraft demon that can hear
you talking through your screen is
strange even by Foundation standards MTF
Edna 84 first discovered scp-4335 in the
single-player server of Minecraft user
leaking heart three team members Jason
yelsen Richard Duchamp and Shelia
Freemason covertly entered the game to
investigate and potentially apprehend
the creature when leaking Hart first
discovered their presence on what he
thought was a private server he quickly
left a little creeped out by the sudden
intrusion thankfully the trio was still
able to locate
scp-4335 they discovered the creature
hiding inside a giant crater as though
it had impacted the Earth at
considerable speed Richard Duchamp who
is the leader of the team at the time
made the mistake of looking directly at
the entity in that moment he experienced
the full force of
scp-4335's Cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes in the
aftermath of this incident Duchamp was
taken off the case and Jason yelson was
promoted to head of the project things
were still going to get stranger Yeltsin
was able to open a dialogue with the
creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world and yelson
informed him that it somehow fallen into
the world of Minecraft instead the
creature was at first confused and then
angry and resentful about its situation
it vowed to find its way into our world
somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this The Entity managed to
breach containment and hop into another
server Yeltsin and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain
it but this time two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed to
the anomalous effects of
scp-4335 they weren't heard but they did
appear strange and incoherent after
experiencing 4335's Cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment
4335 was contained shortly thereafter
once again Yeltsin came face to face
with his new phone eight months after
being captured 4335 granted Yeltsin
another interview from containment 4335
admitted that it almost respected
Yeltsin and the rest of the foundation
for figuring out how to capture and
contain it so quickly in exchange it
would give the foundation something
extremely valuable information first it
asked one question of yelson how does he
Define creation yosin replied uh
something that is built and brought into
this universe by a Sapient being using
other things from this universe 4335
agreed it went on to explain that it
came from a universe devoid of creation
a dark and unknowable place filled with
nothing but violent random chaos its
Dimension existed directly above ours
and it often looked down at us through a
dimensional window fascinated by all the
creation below it plotted and dreamed to
one day infiltrate our reality and yes
and finally had the opportunity to ask
the magic question why though he wasn't
quite ready for the brutal honesty of
scp-4335's reply I do not like to lie so
I will tell you now I wish to suck it
dry of the toys of whatever Force
controls your Universe destroy the light
destroy the Earth and Destroy Humanity
it reminded me of me a blubbering mass
of intelligence and order it sickens me
in ways I cannot comprehend I hope you
understand
scp-4335 was a connoisseur of creation
and it sought to devour all of it in
this moment Yeltsin realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
Minecraft instead of our
which appeared to be the only thing that
saved us but Yeltsin didn't have time to
think 4335 was about to Stage another
daring escape attempt one of its
tendrils reached out and attacked
yelson's player character in that moment
the real-life yelson began to
hallucinate and panic suddenly back in
the game a series of abnormally tall
slender black figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber
around
scp-4335 it had somehow summoned new
minions into the game to assist in this
Containment Breach Jason yelson entered
Cognito Hazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one
affected by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own games the foundation managed to find
a solution they contacted Mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools they're now known as the
Enderman and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for
scp-4335 but there's only one question
left why did The Entity fall into
Minecraft rather than our world the file
posits the most likely answer because
4335 defines creation as elements made
by Sapient beings in Minecraft the most
popular game in the world at the height
of 4335's power everything that exists
is the product of code made by humans
creation is truly abundant there as for
our world in
scp-4335's extra dimensional eyes there
is no Nation no intelligent design no
soothing piano soundtrack just
frightening chaotic Randomness which is
too unlike its own Dimension so even if
scp-4335 ever did arrive in our reality
it would likely be disappointed by how
little there is to eat have you ever
seen something you weren't supposed to
something that made you feel off
something you regret Secrets like these
are Best Kept to yourself but since
you're still alive whatever you saw
wasn't nearly as bad as what Peter
Holland saw one fateful night in January
of 2015. Peter was an unremarkable man
an office worker slaving away at The
Daily Grind and like a lot of people
Peter enjoyed nothing more than coming
home after a long hard day kicking back
and watching some TV it was this
innocent activity that led to Peter's
horrifying brush with
scp-5049 altering the course of his
otherwise average life forever the event
started at around 1005 PM Peter was
channel surfing glued to the couch in
his sparsely furnished apartment
commercials commercials commercials as
far as Peter's tired eyes could see he
paused for a moment to watch the end of
an ad for a car he could never hope to
afford on his salary but something
stopped him from changing the channel
again the next ad had begun and it was
playing a strange scratchy jingle that
gave Peter an odd sense of unease but
even Stranger Than That was the text on
screen demon Dan's Discount homunculus
Depot in baby blue bubble lettering he
forced a smile this had to be some weird
comedy skit or viral marketing campaign
or maybe it was something he drank but
no this was a real commercial and things
were about to get even weirder the Pepe
logo faded to a concerning site a tall
humanoid figure dressed like a used car
salesman but one that definitely wasn't
human his skin was dark green and
covered in patches of thick fur he had
long fingers with intimidating Claws and
a grin full of needle-like fangs it
looked almost demonic and after a few
seconds the demon began to speak hey
there folks it's a man demon Dan coming
at you with the latest and greatest
deals from demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot we've just accepted a
shipment of brand new models that would
make even the most Discerning customers
went with excitement let's see what
we've got the creature apparently named
demon Dan stepped away from his desk
revealing two long furry goat legs that
ended in large pointed Hooves Peter now
assumed he really was going crazy but at
this point he was along for the ride
demon Dan continued his pitch looking to
make your way through the capitalist
hellscape that makes home look cozy come
try one of our newest businessman models
Dan gestured behind him to where Peter
was horrified to see a total of 52 adult
male human bodies hanging from a wall
there was something uncanny about them
they seemed almost Hollow like a highly
realistic costume or a prop from a
horror movie Peter didn't have much time
to think about it though as demon Dan
went on if your
if your challenge of inequality the
businesswoman model may be a right fit
for you the commercial then revealed a
wall of human female bodies strung up in
a similar fashion now you may be
thinking but and business sounds hot I
just want to have some fun and the fine
team here at demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot have got you covered
the camera zoomed out to show an area of
the store filled with children's
decorations and more of these strange
hollowed-out human suits in child sizes
to match and
kids no one
limiters of any child size unit comes
with a
with a sent off coupon for parental
units you just can't say no to a deal
like that before Peter could process the
madness that was unfolding before him
the camera cut again the store's logo
appeared on the screen once more along
with several cuts to locations around
the store itself there are more human
bodies hundreds of them demon Dan's
sleazy voice rang out over all of it
here I demon dance discount homunculus
Depot we know it's not all fun and games
the brightest Among Us have a mission to
accomplish the seven Lords are ever
planning their Invasion after all so
you're looking for function over form
well we've got that in Spades down here
in the Tactical Services Department
you'll be kicking Us in no time when
you're wearing the latest models at the
best prices seven Lords Invasion what
did any of this mean suddenly the camera
was showing him a new room red curtains
parted revealing more of these person
suits several bearing a striking
resemblance to real human celebrities he
managed to make out Gucci Mane Avril
Lavigne Paul McCartney and Britney
Spears before demon Dan's appearance
once again drew his attention I've got a
special treat for you we're happy to
announce the VIP look-alike Department
we all know how difficult the creation
of homunculus is it's a fine art that
takes years of practice so when a
replacement order on VIPs comes in every
detail needs to be perfect unfortunately
really that's not always the case but
for the right price you too can look
like famous icons from around the globe
the image of celebrity bodies faded from
View and Peter was left looking at the
grinning demon Dan standing behind the
front desk of his impossible store once
more he said there you have it folks
come on down to demon dance discount
homunculus Depot if you're viewing the
advertisement then you've been selected
for entry please enter the nearest door
for instant deals and upgrade those old
Duds for one of our newest models what
are you waiting for come on down the
logo popped up again hovering above some
bold text that said please enter the
nearest door Peter had had enough he
switched off the TV what a horror show
he thought they should just warn you
before they put short horror films on TV
like that he had no idea they could just
slip them in among regular commercials
Shirley demon Dan in this store couldn't
be real right but as his eyes drifted to
the door in his room he didn't feel feel
quite so certain well there was only one
way to find out Peter got up went over
to the door took a deep breath and
walked through it Peter Holland was
never seen again not as himself anyway
the SCP Foundation has long been aware
of this Sinister transmission known as
scp-5049-2 and luckily has found ways to
prevent it from claiming more victims
the foundation television analysis
Department as well as web crawler 40y 40
which is the software the foundation
uses to root out anomalous activity
online are always vigilant for signs of
demon Dan's commercial running just
observing demon Dan who is himself
classified as
scp-5049-a and his ads put you in
immediate danger as they can transform
any nearby doors into
scp-5049-1s those are interdimensional
portals that remain active for around 15
minutes after viewing the ad so then
what specifically is
scp-5049 it's the entire pocket
Dimension known as demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot a cutie or class
spatial anomaly constantly on the
lookout for new human victims which it
transforms into fleshy suits for its
demonic clients which let them blend in
around humans prior to its Discovery by
the foundation it's likely that demon
Dan and his associates claimed hundreds
if not thousands of lives but sadly even
discovering this anomaly came at a
gruesome cost to the foundation on
February 16 2020 the ad played on safe
storage Warehouse 13's break room
television at the time of the broadcast
four Foundation Personnel were present
including security agent William Birkin
worrying that this was a potential
security threat agent Birkin
investigated the door to a nearby closet
the second he opened it he was
transformed to the storefront of demon
Dan's Discount homunculus Depot he saw
demon Dan himself standing at the corner
while four smaller reptilian Ms fought
over a small flesh suit demon Dan
scolded them before turning his
attention to agent Perkin does testis
you aren't supposed to be here little
man how naughty I'm gonna have to have a
word with marketing once I'm through
with you agent Burkin fearing for his
safety drew his weapon and shot demon
damn three times the creature
dematerialized before appearing right
next to agent Birkin and disarming him
with a swift chop the unfortunate
security agent was then grabbed by the
considerably larger demon Dan and thrown
over Dan's shoulder we know all of this
because agent birkin's standard issue
Foundation body camera recorded the
whole terrifying ordeal even as demon
Dan dragged the helpless Birkin back
into the Twisted Workshop behind the
store there Birkin saw what would soon
be his own fate right before his eyes
Dan's minions converting human bodies
into fleshy suits for their demon
clientele and this unfortunate security
officer was next Dan gave him over to a
pair of large sheep like demons and told
them to drain skin and declaw him
birkin's video feed finally cut as the
demons pulled out the rusty tools and
began to work on him of course the SCP
Foundation wouldn't take an attack on
one of their operatives inside one of
their facilities no less lying down the
unfortunate death of William Birkin
allowed the foundation to refine their
methods of intercepting the broadcast of
demon Dan's commercials they even had a
new mobile Task Force Mobile Strike
Force Kappa 11 or the Baphomet Bashers
specifically to deal with demon Dan and
his cronies they did more than just
prevent him from taking new humans
though when the Baphomet Bashers teamed
up with an A-Class Clairvoyant entity to
improve their efficiency in predicting
future broadcasts they were able to
launch sting operations and arrest 21
different demonic customers for
interrogation this impressive strike
back finally gave the foundation some
meaningful leverage over demon Dan and
through the use of their Clairvoyant
entity they were able to call a
temporary truce and arrange a meeting
with demon Dan himself Captain Steiner
an agent of the foundation external
negotiation Department was the one to
interrogate demon Dan they sat across
from each other at a table and Demon Dan
was clearly tense frustrated with the
way the foundation had been messing with
his business all of their sting
operations were frightening off his
customers in return for letting him
continue his work the foundation wanted
Dan to turn over all the information on
his bosses and customers allowing the
foundation to track their movements when
Dan was evasive about whether he'd
comply they tried threatening him Dan
laughed them off go ahead take your best
shot little man there's a dozen more
just like me you won't stop anything
finally he was pressured into giving a
yes or no answer as to whether he'd
willingly collaborate with the
foundation and act as an informant
against his kind when demon Dan hinted
that he may be willing to comply he
began to make a horrifying gurgling
noise and gripped his head in pain he
began speaking in Latin in a voice that
wasn't his own as though the seven demon
Lords he served were speaking through
him they said you are a fool Jailer to
think a pathetic morso such as this
could Aid you against us I have allowed
you to toil in your own delusions for
far too long you may have taken
advantage of azimodius all those years
ago but you stop nothing You Hinder
nothing you jail and barter to no avail
your time is coming and then demon Dan's
head exploded which obviously prevented
him from giving any incriminating
information on those he worked for
whoever the demon Lords are there's
certainly the secretive type you may
think that this is the end of Demon
dance discount homunculus Depot and of
scp-5049 but soon another ad ran it
advertised the same products and
services out of the same store the only
difference was that this time a
different entity was starring in it it
was July of 2004 and Bill Murray was
enjoying the peak of an extremely
successful career
not only had the iconic actors starred
in some of the most beloved comedies of
the 20th century including Ghostbusters
and Groundhog Day he'd voiced the main
character of the recently released
live-action Garfield movie it'd been a
financial success but it was a critical
flop not that this bothered Bill he was
happy with the performance and the
paycheck
what he wouldn't be quite as happy about
was the horrifying encounter he was
about to have with scp-3166
on July 8th bill was enjoying a cold
drink on the porch of his luxurious
Beverly Hills Home the sky was beginning
to darken as the sun set in the west it
was a blissful evening his wife Jennifer
was inside watching TV nothing seemed
particularly out of the ordinary until
he noticed a quick flash of orange in
the distance it was almost too fast to
register this large orange-shaped
darting past the corner of his eye for a
second he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escaped Tiger but
it was gone too fast to really tell Bill
finished his drink and headed inside he
had enough for one night the next
morning he got up to read the paper and
found the Garfield movie getting
slaughtered by the critics one review
stated no one can accuse Garfield the
movie of infidelity to its source it
Faithfully conveys the banality of Jim
Davis's cartoon another called it a film
without energy and without spirit
you put the paper down and ate his
breakfast a few blows to the ego were
worth it for the paydays that came with
big budget family films just then his
wife came to him with a strange question
were you walking around downstairs in
the middle of the night no he hadn't
he'd been sleeping like a baby why did
she ask well Jennifer said I heard some
rustling downstairs last night
it sounded like something big
he hadn't heard anything though and told
her it was probably just Her Imagination
he put it out of his mind and continued
about his day he decided he would keep
his eyes peeled for that orange blur
again though Bill didn't see anything
peculiar the rest of the morning and
went to a local cafe for lunch he
ordered a coffee and a cream cheese
bagel then made a quick trip to the
bathroom while his food was prepared
when Bill returned to his table though
there was something strange
instead of a bagel there was a large
heaping of lasagna on the table what was
going on this Cafe didn't even serve
lasagna Bill knew something was terribly
wrong things only got stranger when bill
came home to find a small tuft of orange
fur snagged on the frame of his front
door and it wasn't synthetic for her
like you'd see on plush toys or stuffed
animals no this was real animal fur
maybe someone was just goofing off or
trying to play some weird prank on him
but it didn't feel like it deep down
Bill Murray knew that he was in grave
danger whoever or whatever was behind
this
it wanted to hurt him that night his
worst fears were realized Bill's wife
had left town for the week and he was
headed to the kitchen in the middle of
the night for a glass of water when he
saw something a huge figure moving up
against the glass door leading to his
backyard the thing was huge nearly seven
feet tall with a bloated fur-covered
misshapen body that was pressed up
against the door its fur was bright
garish orange a cartoon or
strangest of all though was the sound it
was making
it sounded like it was purring Bill
backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide the whole night
he sat cowering as he heard scratching
against the walls like something was
trying to get in he was terrified and
too scared to do anything even move
finally as morning broke the noises
seemed to stop Bill had to do something
he couldn't let this nightmare go on
another night what if things got worse
what if that thing managed to get inside
he called the local police and when they
arrived he explained the incredibly
strange situation as best he could he
told them he was being stalked by some
kind of huge cat or at least someone
dressed like a huge cat also there was
lasagna involved the officers
interviewing him could barely contain
their laughter as he told them his story
a giant orange cat perhaps one of them
theorized he angered some kind of
obsessive Garfield fan through his
involvement in the live-action movie
after all the original comic had been
running for years and had been extremely
popular who knows what kind of nut jobs
were obsessed with seeing only a fateful
adaptation of the source material as the
officers departed bill was confident
that they weren't taking him seriously
he couldn't rely on any of them for
protection thankfully from a
multi-decade movie career he had plenty
of disposable income and decided to hire
a private security team to protect him
while he looked into this mystery he had
two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month
they were armed and given the cryptic
orders to fire on anything orange
meanwhile Bill began to Fall Down A
Garfield Rabbit Hole he felt strangely
compelled to research all the Garfield
media he could find as though the answer
to his terrifying situation was somehow
hidden between the lines Bill explored
the entire backlog of thousands of comic
strips he read the books and interviews
with Jim Davis he watched the cartoons
and straight to DVD animated movies
ironically for a guy who'd recently
trade the lasagna loving orange cat Bill
had never felt quite so immersed in the
character before
he found the strange Pathos in the
routine of Garfield and his friends one
particular comic really piqued his
interest though originally published in
October of 1989 the comic began with
Garfield being woken up by a strange
Chell and almost Eerie sensation the
character observed aloud that he didn't
feel like he was in his own home he
explored his little home further trying
to find his owner John or his housemate
and sometimes Nemesis Odie but found
nothing as Garfield remarked on feeling
alone a purple speechbox delivered the
Sinister message
you have no idea how alone you are
Garfield he then finds that his home
looks like it's been abandoned for years
the for sale sign outside is practically
ancient
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying
Revelation everyone really is God in his
adventures and friends now exist only in
his imagination he's trapped in a prison
of his own creation trying to Stave off
his endless loneliness
in denial about the reality of his
situation the comic ended with a quote
directly from Jim Davis himself saying
an imagination is a powerful tool it
content memories of the past shade
perceptions of the present or paint a
future so vivid that it can entice or
terrify all depending upon how we
conduct ourselves today as he read those
words Bill Murray felt a chill down his
spine why had he wanted to get involved
in the Garfield movie in the first place
what had he gotten himself into before
he could slip any deeper into his own
mind Bill heard a faint choked scream
downstairs
he felt his breath catch in his throat
he was terrified but needed to see what
was happening
carefully and quietly began to creep
down the stairs at the bottom he poked
his head around a corner and that's when
he saw a member of his security detail
lying dead on the floor his face was
Blue from asphyxiation his mouth was
stuffed with lasagna
it looked like he had been force-fed to
death
they wanted to scream but he couldn't or
maybe knew he shouldn't just then he
heard a soft meaty thumping noise coming
from the nearby living room he didn't
know why but he felt compelled to
approach as if by forces Beyond his
control he made his way to the living
room and when he'd got there he saw
where the noise was coming from Bill's
jaw dropped in pure horror there was the
other member of his security detail
lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure who was a grotesquely huge
creature wearing what looked to be a
kind of crude Garfield outfit made of
sewn together cat palettes it's stank of
pasta and rotten meat in its giant Paw
It held the golden trophy which it was
using to pound the security guard's head
into mush while making quiet cat-like
purring noises the creature suddenly
stopped and looked up locking eyes with
Bill the fear of death came over him he
froze as the giant freakish Garfield
stepped over Donny's corpse and began to
come towards him bill turned and ran but
Garfield was gaining on him before he
could make it to the front door the
creature knocked him over he was laid
out on the ground looking up at it as it
reached into its own body cavity and
began to pull out handfuls of lasagna he
was about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill's mouth when
suddenly a ding Was Heard and the
creature stopped looked up as if
sniffing the air and then suddenly
turned and lumbered towards the kitchen
Bill watched as the Garfield monster
entered the kitchen where somehow there
was a steaming hot fresh lasagna sitting
in the open oven the creature had sensed
the presence of external lasagna and
felt the compulsion to integrate it into
its body grabbing fistfuls and shoving
it into itself
just then a group of highly trained SCP
Foundation Personnel burst into the room
and subdued the creature
had been an ambush the foundation had
been tipped off to the presence of the
creature by monitoring the local police
department dispatches and the report of
a seven foot tall comic book CAD
terrorizing a Hollywood actor was
definitely worth looking into the
monster that had almost taken Bill
Murray's life was
scp-3166 a deadly pathophysical being
that tends to manifest around people
somehow involved in the Garfield
intellectual property it appears
whenever the public perception of
Garfield falls out of favor and because
Bill had starred in the critically pan
Garfield movie he was currently at the
very top of
scp-3166's Hit List
thankfully he managed to survive his
terrifying ordeal and was administered
amnestics by Foundation Personnel so
that he could return to his normal life
this frightening and mysterious creature
has been around since 1989 appearing
after the publication of The Haunting
Garfield comic that Bill had read that
very night
it appeared in the office of United
media who were the Publishers of the
Garfield comic strip at the time
and began wrecking Havoc since then the
creature's manifestation has been a
constant threat whenever Garfield loses
its popularity or audience as a result
the foundation has spent years as the
funding source behind all Garfield media
and even planting hypnotic mimetics into
the comic strips to ensure that there is
always a loyal fan base the fur is
indeed real organic cat fur albeit an
unnaturally orange color and instead of
organs the creature is filled with
lasagna worst of all though is that
testing has revealed that the meat in
the lasagna is genetically identical to
the Flesh of Garfield's Creator Jim
Davis how did this thing come into
existence perhaps it was Jim's sheer
force of imagination that dragged it
into being as he himself said an
imagination is a powerful tool all in
all it's lucky that Bill Murray was able
to survive his encounter and return to
his normal life well as normal as life
can be for Bill Murray and if you see
Bill Murray don't bother asking him
about scp-3166
the amnestics were quite effective and
just as he's fond of saying himself
no one will ever believe you your new
SCP Foundation researcher on tour of
site 17 familiarizing yourself with the
location and its many anomalous
inhabitants it's the second largest
Foundation containment site out there
and it's also the kind of job that most
Junior researchers dream of low-risk
humanoid containment baby most of the
inhabitants in your sector are cordial
willing to comply with orders from staff
and seeing for all intents and purposes
pretty much human you pass from door to
door looking through the viewing hatch
of each one you can't believe what
you're seeing it's a wonderful who's who
of anomalous humanoids you see the wise
bearded face of scp-343 known to some as
God you see the blue eyes and Shining
blonde hair of Iris as cp105 looking
wistfully into a Polaroid picture you
see the tanned melancholic face of Kane
scp-073 as he stares off into the middle
distance face after face after face
passes you can see yourself getting more
familiar with each one yes your time
here will be wait was that Hitler you
stop and walk back to the door you just
passed where you can't help but stop and
stare in disbelief yes it's him it's got
to be him you recognize the unpleasant
sneer the Hideous comb over the silly
little toothbrush mustache the SCP
Foundation seems to have Adolf Hitler
the former leader of the Third Reich in
World War II in active containment and
his designation is
scp-2430 you've seen Killer toasters and
masks that can take over people's minds
but you've never seen anything as
surreal as this you immediately run to
your Superior and ask how and why Hitler
is in one of the site-17 humanoid
containment cells Buckle in because we
can guarantee it's one of the most
insane stories you've ever heard it's
late April 1945 and the Soviets are
rampaging through Nazi Germany
destroying everything in their path the
German forces have been nearly
obliterated and Hitler and the rest of
his Reich chancellory have retreated to
a secure bunker beneath Berlin there on
April 30th 10 days after his 56th
birthday Hitler died this was truly
unfortunate for the Soviets as they wish
to have had the chance to kill him
themselves two days later Soviet forces
stormed the fury bunker it was little
more than a formality at that point as
the news of Hitler's death had already
gone public by the time they arrived all
that was left of Hitler was a pile of
mostly burned remains A fitting end for
someone who had caused the same cruel
fate for so many others they collected
what was left of Hitler's body and
brought it back to the Fatherland a kind
of trophy for their Nation but Hitler
dying before Joseph Stalin could get his
hands on him was not what Stalin wanted
Hitler had not only caused the deaths of
millions of Russians he had personally
betrayed Stalin's trust and when you
betray Stalin bad things happen to you
very very bad things two years earlier
in 1943 Soviet forces had raided the
camp in genowiska belonging to the
obscura Corps think of them as the
Nazi's own version of the SCP Foundation
who were hell-bent on Gathering
anomalous people and artifacts to
increase the power of the Third Reich
they were a far more militant offshoot
of the tool Society a group that
described itself as a study group for
Germanic Antiquity while this may seem
innocent the Teo Society was actually a
racist cult closely aligned with the
goals and ideas of the German Nazi party
many have also speculated that they were
heavily involved in the occult and it's
this mysticism obsessed offshoot that
went on to form the obscura corpse and
in their janowaska base they'd obtained
a hundred pieces of Enchanted occult
flesh with human skeletons embedded in
each of them this flesh was believed to
originate from the mythological surimner
the Beast hunted and eaten again and
again by the pantheon of Norse gods
having the qualities of both a wild boar
and the Goat the flesh can bond to
skeletons and give them a quality
somewhat like immortality any flesh cut
from them will regrow time and time
again if given a rest period now that he
had both the Flesh of surimner and
Hitler's burnt remains Stalin had an
idea a perfect way to not only bring
satisfaction to the Russian people and
the world but to finally exact the true
Revenge that Hitler had denied to him he
called it project judica namely after
the very bottom level of Hell reserved
for betrayers like Judas a perfect
tribute for an old Ally turned enemy he
couldn't kill Hitler before but if
Stalin was going to get the chance
Hitler needed to live again for years
Stalin's top scientists try to use
Arcane methods to resurrect Hitler by
combining his remains with the Flesh of
suramir at times they even came close to
creating a new Hitler but there was one
huge issue the creature they created
could not feel pain and for Stalin's
plans of violent and painful retribution
the lack of suffering simply would not
do they destroyed what they had created
and went back to the drawing board
Stalin would stop at nothing to get what
he wanted even if it meant breaking
every law of nature in the process in
order to make his Twisted dream a
reality Stahl informed an Unholy
alliance with a group known as the
uralic fleshcrafters a neo-sarkic cult
that was a branch of the nightmarish
religion of sarcasism this group
essentially worships avatars of Flesh
corruption and disease and are behind
some of the most terrifying and
disgusting anomalies out there including
the flesh that hates and the bone
Orchard true sarcasists who show the
proper Devotion to their vile deities
and know the right rituals to contact
them are often granted anomalous powers
that spread the sarkic influence further
across the known Dimensions these Powers
will usually involve having a
supernatural ability to manipulate the
Flesh of themselves and others allowing
them to enhance their bodies cheat death
and warp their enemies Beyond repair
they can sometimes even create life if
they're a powerful enough acolyte of
psychicism and it was because of these
powers that Stalin wanted the erolic
flesh Crafters under his command in
exchange for their participation he
would give them a vast quantity of the
Flesh of suramir which they could use
for their own Sinister sarkic purposes a
deal was struck and the true work of
resurrecting Hitler began Stalin was
very specific in his requirements he
gave the uralic fleshcrafters extra
bones to compensate for what had gone
missing from Hitler's burnt remains he
also gave them samples of the Flesh of
saramir to achieve the desired effects
of a near Immortal tolerance for damage
however Stalin demanded that he
heightened this new Hitler's capacity to
experience pain so that every suffering
inflicted on him would be three times
worse than anyone else and true to their
word the flesh Crafters got to work and
began creating just such a creature by
now it was the early 1950s and Stalin
was putting the pieces in place for his
Grand Revenge once the new Hitler was
finished he would hold a new trial for
him in the Russian courts where he would
preside over the sentencing personally
once the new Hitler was done the uralic
fleshcrafters were rewarded for their
participation in Project Utica with four
thousand kilograms of the Flesh of
saramir Stalin now had his very own
personal Hitler chew toy that he could
maim and torture as much as he pleased
knowing that he would always heal and
soon be ready for more in their infinite
generosity the fleshcrafters even taught
Stalin a new method of Torment for his
old enemy a process known as the right
of nyas it's a torture that's been
described by many as being like the
Chinese Ling Chi also known as the
linger during death or slow slicing but
it is probably best known as the death
by a Thousand Cuts the Soviets and the
sarkix parted ways for the next few
years Stalin took a great deal of
pleasure in visiting Hitler's cage now
and then to torture him until Stalin
himself eventually passed away from
natural causes the grup division which
is essentially the Soviet answer to the
SCP Foundation decided it would be best
to do away with the immortal Hitler
clone after Stalin's death he no longer
served any purpose and no matter how
hard they tried they couldn't
permanently kill him either in the end
they settled on a kind of compromise he
would be buried alive and forgotten
forced to live a torturous eternity that
he could never Escape until of course he
was dug up and rescued by none other
than the members of obscura a modern
splinter group of the original obscura
corpse like many high-profile Nazis
who'd escaped the war the new Hitler was
Spirited Away to a safe house run by
sympathizers in Arjun Tina the ones
taking care of him received the
following correspondence from the
obscura agents who'd first dug the new
Hitler back up they have managed to
rescue zafira and bring him to safety
but he is effectively dead on the inside
I blames the Reds for their inhumane
treatment of zafira who may have been
Bewitched by zerez vandavath a wish we
could merciful him but we've tried
everything he just won't perish don't
abandon him he's too distinct in plain
sight they didn't have the new Hitler
for long though in 1960 efforts to hunt
down the remaining Nazi fugitives
increased in intensity the new Hitler
was soon captured by Mossad agents
searching for Nazis in Buenos Aires and
then remanded to the containment of the
SCP Foundation when they realized that
he had a number of anomalous properties
such as his incredible regenerative
abilities as well as the fact that his
DNA seems to be based on that of a wild
boar and a goat rather than a human
however x-rays conducted by the
foundation have discovered traces of
cyanide still in his system system as
well as traces of lead in his skull
where the bone has regrown over the
bullet in other words it was
unquestionably the real Hitler and he
was now in Foundation custody
forevermore it's such a wild story even
by Foundation standards that you can
barely summon the words to respond once
your supervisor is finished he just
stands there with a slight smile basking
in your amazement before you can even
ask again he confirms the facts one more
time yes it is the real Hitler the only
functional difference is that he can't
die and he has a heightened sense of
pain compared to most people you think
on what you've been told for just a
moment and then you have only one
question are we allowed to punch him
your supervisor smiles and says of
course we all do feeling hungry maybe
you could go for a snack right about now
or a nice refreshing can of your
favorite soda perhaps if you've got some
change burning a hole in your pocket a
nearby vending machine would be a good
choice and trust us there's no vetting
machine like this one
scp-261 will give you a treat that's out
of this world or rather out of this
Dimension that's how this safe class
anomaly earned its incredibly accurate
name the interdimensional vending
machine it was first discovered in a
dark alley in Yokohama Japan Japan is a
place where you can find a number of
strange and surprising things in vending
machines but nothing quite like this the
foundation was first alerted to its
presence after one of their web trawlers
noticed some interesting chatter on
Japanese online message boards about a
magic vending machine to these Japanese
form users it sounded like a fanciful
urban legend a vending machine where you
could get something truly Fantastical if
you have the yen to spare but upon
thorough investigation field agents of
the SCP Foundation discovered that the
machine was no Legend and brought it
into containment it's the kind of thing
you wouldn't look twice at an utterly
generic black vending machine machine
with no viewing window and a handwritten
sign in Japanese that reads out of order
but what the vending machine looks like
isn't nearly as interesting as what it's
capable of when you insert your money
into the machine and it's important to
note that it only accepts Japanese Yen
the machine will dispense some kind of
snack food or drink item however over
time the more the machine is used in a
single day the more bizarre the items it
spits out will become Foundation
researchers have attempted to figure out
how the machine works but their task has
been incredibly difficult so far it
doesn't appear to contain any snacks and
it doesn't seem to be made of any
anomalous Parts moreover the machine
simply won't work when the front panel
is opened or when any surveillance
equipment is placed inside in other
words it's pretty much impossible to
look this gift horse in the mouth
strangely the machine is also capable of
working without power though when
unpowered the vended products are likely
to become strain danger much faster but
let's be honest here you're not here for
vending machine mechanics 101 you want
to hear about all the weird stuff that
scp-261 dispenses and frankly we're with
you on that one lucky for all of us this
is one of the anomalies that the
foundation has truly extensive test
records on providing us with a highlight
rail of some of the strangest wildest
and downright most interesting snacks
and drinks straight out of another
dimension Bon Appetit let's start off
nice and easy with some of the snacks
and drinks that are not only edible but
also sound like they'd actually be
pretty tasty like Pepsi Dragon twist a
bottle of Pepsi soda with English
packaging that tastes like dragon fruit
PepsiCo does not produce such a product
but honestly we wish they did same for
Dark Side Cola a clear liquid that
becomes jet black shortly after being
open which apparently tastes like your
average can of coke with the Touch of
Spice thrown in but hey not everybody
likes Cola maybe you're a Maverick a
rebel only a soft drink with a formal
title can quench your thirst and as such
you prefer Dr Pepper in which case maybe
the vending machine will furnish you
with an interdimensional Japanese
product known as Dr Pepper's amusing
straw this spatial anomaly wrapped
inside a Whimsical Dr Pepper branded
straws seems to contain far more liquid
than should be able to fit in the straw
about one bottle's worth of soda to be
precise a nice and convenient solution
for whenever you need to get the fix
that only an accredited doctor of
popology can provide and if you fancy
something from the more intoxicating end
of the beverage Spectrum for 600 Yen you
can get yourself a rare bottle of Billy
beer it's just the thing for those who
weren't alive during the Carter
Administration but still want to try
brew that was endorsed by the younger
brother of President Jimmy Carter this
anomalous bottle of Suds which was
bottled in the 1970s according to its
label came with a note reading I had
this beer brewed just for me I I think
it's the best I've ever tasted and I've
tasted a lot I think you'd like it too
Billy Carter drinking the beer got a
d-class intoxicated for 72 hours but
what if you've just wet your whistle and
worked up a hunger in the process
thankfully scp-261 has some delicious
interdimensional food to satisfy your
Cravings so for starters how about a
tube of the little Bakery Seven Grain
this small aluminum tube lets you
squeeze out a blob of dough which
instantly Rises and Cooks itself into a
tasty little loaf of bread testing has
indicated that the bread is a little
chewy but still tastes completely fine
not bad for a tubed baked good how about
some seafood to go with that bread then
maybe for your entree you can crack open
a delicious pack of lemon clams and we
do mean crack very literally here if you
crack this bag of anomalous clams like a
glow stick they boil themselves and once
you open them you're ready to enjoy a
serving of tasty clams that have a
slight lemon flavoring to them delicious
but if you're not that hungry and just
feeling more like a snack than a full
fancy dinner the machine once put out
the Lay's blooming onion while it
appears to be a normal onion each layer
of the onion is a different flavor of
Chip leading all the way into the middle
truly a gourmet snack with more layers
than well actually exactly as many
layers as an onion and what about for
those who are anomalously trapped in the
year 2012 and are looking for a snack
that is both tasty and meanworthy while
you'd be lucky to receive a 700 Yen
bacon shirt it's exactly what it says on
the can an edible shirt that both smells
and tastes like bacon and has no real
side effects other than making you smell
a little like bacon while you're wearing
it though this could be a dangerous
anomalous effect if you decide to walk
through your local dog park while you're
wearing it we've been told it pairs well
with the meat hat Teriyaki Fedora a size
64 Trilby style Fedora made entirely out
of Teri flavored beef jerky the object
came flattened in a cardboard box
bearing the tagline you can have your
hat and eat it too which is a pun that
probably makes a lot more sense in their
Dimension still a bit hungry well lucky
for you this magical vending machine has
got you covered on dessert too for 700
Yen the foundation was given an entire
edible chess set with each of the ornate
pieces carved from what seemed like hard
Pez Style candy it's less Checkmate and
more check eight another pun that I
promise is funnier in another dimension
and for 300 Yen extra you might walk
away with a candy robot playset these
are more hard candy components that can
be put together to create functional
anomalous mini robots that move on their
own walking aimlessly and bumping into
walls but what about the full meal
craving consumer on the go who wants
both a dinner and a dessert combined
into one disgusting package don't worry
the interdimensional vending machine has
got you covered just 400 Yen can net you
some delicious Turtle
these are balls of fried turkey filled
with chocolate a smaller ball of duck
more chocolate and in the very center a
small ball of fried chicken even the
labeling on the product describes it as
having 450 percent of an adult human's
daily recommended fat intake we'll leave
it to you to decide if this is a
decadent treat worthy of the gods or
utterly disgusting maybe you're feeling
a little cheeky though or you need the
perfect comedic dessert for your
bachelorette party the vending machine
has a candy direct from an alternate
Korea a tasty if slightly too sweet
chocolate candy shaped like a certain
male organ filled with we kid you not
liquid white chocolate perfect for
anyone who has both the sweet tooth and
the sense of humor of a 12 year old okay
these were definitely all weird Treats
but let's get really really strange now
from the disgusting to the confused
using to the inedible to the straight up
deadly if you're a bit of a sadist
perhaps you're the kind of person who
enjoys watching their snacks dying in
front of them before they eat them for
that the vending machine provides an
aluminum box with a viewing window and a
red button on top inside are a
collection of small furry creatures each
with a single big eye when the button is
pressed the creatures inside are
abruptly superheated cooking them all to
death at that point the Box opens and
the creatures are ready to eat we've
been told they were crunchy spicy and
tasted a little like beef maybe you're
part of the slow food movement for that
we recommend the delicious pile of slugs
which is exactly what it sounds like
this is a produce box like the kind used
for packing strawberries except it's
full of live slugs there are both
advantages and disadvantages to actually
eating these slugs the advantage is that
they contain large amounts of vitamin C
E and most of the B complex which are
all crucial to a healthy and balanced
diet the disadvantage is that they
contain large amounts of arsenic which
will kill you though of course if you
still have a candy flavored death wish
but you prefer your entomological treats
a little more leggy then may we interest
you in a fine caramelized spider for a
modest 500 yen it's full of deadly
quantities of an unknown anomalous Venom
that's pretty much impossible to cure
but it's worth it for the Sweet Sticky
goodness that comes before death sets in
another strange item dispensed by the
vending machine was a tall metal
aluminum canister with a ring pole that
upon opening had a violent chemical
reaction with the air and triggered a
large explosion apparently this
particular beverage was never intended
for oxygenated environments the blast
killed two researchers and resulted in
the temporary suspension of testing
though in a slight silver lining for
this Fiasco the testing area did smell
of citrus for a few days which the
janitors must have enjoyed as they
cleaned up all the body parts another
dangerous snack provided by the vending
machine was a long tube of chips called
Pringles not to be confused with any
other long two base chips you may be
thinking of when the tube was opened or
popped as they say the d-class that the
chips were presented to began
compulsively eating them when
researchers ordered the d-class to stop
it seemed almost as if they couldn't
regardless of the orders given to them
the d-class just kept eating even when
guards terminated the d-class there and
then the corpse continued to eat ships
out of the tube until it was physically
pried out of their hands but if all
those salty Pringles had really worked
up a thirst in you perhaps you can wash
them down with a delicious can of Cherry
Bomb an intense cherry flavored drink
dispensed by scp-261 for 450 Yen when a
d-class sampled this delicious soda they
commented on it tasting strongly of
cherry a few moments later their head
exploded with the force of a stick of
dynamite coating everyone and everything
around it in gooey head viscera the
resulting cleanup took an arduous six
hours but wow was that cherry tasty and
finally why not complete this anomalous
vending machine Feast with a 1 000 Yen
paper mache pinata resembling a dead
horse that comes ready to use with a
baseball bat everyone who saw the pinata
fell compelled to beat it mercilessly
with the bat until candy began to fall
out many in attendance claimed that it
was the one thousandth gift Unleashed by
scp-261 and thus warranted celebration
once the dead horse was thoroughly
beaten all Cognito hazardous properties
ceased there's a joke somewhere in there
but for the life of us we're not sure we
can find it oh wow maybe it's in another
dimension we hope you're ready folks
because today we're discussing the most
dangerous SCP of all time we know you've
probably heard heard this before but
seriously this one is the absolute top
of the Pyramid of fear or the fear amid
if you will this SCP makes 682 weep in
Terror for its life it makes the old man
scp-106 consider turning his life around
and taking up a career in humanitarian
work it even makes the dreaded Scarlet
King himself the Lord of chaos the
ultimate despair quake and his spiky red
boots it's just that utterly terrifying
just kidding it's Lego but we had you
going there for a second didn't we
though it may not actually be the
scariest anomaly of all time
scp-387 isn't your granddad's Lego set
either unless your granddad goes by
agent Hardy and works for the SCP
Foundation Hardy is one of the hundreds
of thousands of foundation field agents
planted all over the globe in everything
from law enforcement to surveillance
ever watchful for the kinds of anomalies
the SCP Foundation makes it their
mission to secure here contain and
protect but when he discovered scp-387
he wasn't even technically on duty he
was taking a long train journey home
from his parents house while his car was
in the shop and as anyone who's ever
taken a long train journey knows without
proper stimulation boredom will crop up
in no time he'd been reading a pretty
interesting book on his e-reader when
tragedy first struck and it ran out of
battery Hardy had forgotten to bring his
charging cable so he was potentially
looking at another three hours of
mind-numbing monotony that's when he
noticed the red plastic tub that had
been apparently abandoned in the seat
across from him he realized in that
moment that had been there the whole
time unsupervised given that he was a
foundation field agent and was as such
extremely curious he grabbed the tub and
took a look inside hoping to find
something that'll quell his growing
boredom lucky for him the box was full
of Lego bricks everyone's favorite brand
of toy construction block the tub was
Brim with a vast collection of pieces
some of which like wheels and prisms
agent Hardy had never seen before
despite spending his childhood
obsessively making Lego constructions
but Hardy wasn't one to criticize a gift
from the universe this tub of Lego
pieces would be the perfect way to keep
himself entertained for the rest of his
long journey he spent the next hour or
so meticulously recreating site 19 in
Lego form on the table in front of him
when the building was done he decided to
have some fun and populate the site with
a collection of Lego men standing in for
SCP Foundation scientists containment
Specialists and guards after fighting a
torso with a lab coat in the Box agent
Hardy decided to make a tiny Dr bright
to start with however as soon as he made
the tiny Lego scientists and set it down
on his new site-19 playset he realized
that everything was not as innocently
typical as it seemed the little man
instantly began to walk immediately
picking up a tiny Lego clipboard and
heading towards the Euclid containment
Wing Asian Hardy he had discovered a
brand new anomaly on his day off while
playing with toys on a boring train ride
philosopher LP Jax was certainly right
when he said a master in The Art of
Living draws no sharp distinction
between his work and his play naturally
agent Hardy immediately took the little
Lego Man Apart along with his sight 19
simulacrum and alerted his superiors at
the SCP Foundation his co-workers met
him at the next train stop platform not
long after the box of seemingly living
Lego pieces redesignated
scp-387 was in the hands of foundation
researcher Dr Arch his first priority
was finding out what exactly they were
all dealing with here whether there was
more of it out there and whether it was
dangerous attempts to investigate the
origins of scp-387 were mostly fruitless
undercover Foundation agents
investigated every Lego producing
location they could find but found no
evidence of anything similar to 387
being produced and of course as with
anything that seemed to be an anomalous
boy all possible links to Dr
wondertainment were also explored but
again nothing came up this was probably
for the best if 387 was a doctor
wondertainment product it probably would
have built itself into an actual sized
dinosaur and started eating people
already all further investigations into
387's Origins were subsequently dropped
with background research turning out to
be a dead end Dr Arch decided to get
down to business doing the fun part
actual experimentation after Gathering
all the proper permissions from his
superiors the testing commenced in
experiment 387-a Dr Arch recruited a
number of Lego loving d-classes after
all even convicted robbers arsonists and
murderers love Lego and made them
construct a little Lego Community inside
a testing chamber this consisted of a
small Main Street with a number of Lego
stores a residential area and a bar as
soon as the d-class is constructed a
variety of little Lego men and released
them into the community they instantly
came to life and began performing their
roles perfectly some took up jobs in the
various stores cafes and boutiques
others acted as patrons for the
different businesses the Lego men were
even noted as forming rudimentary family
units one man did fall into the river in
this Lego City but otherwise things were
going smoothly encouraged by these
developments Dr Arch was ready to begin
the true experiment introducing a
complex new variable into the
environment of the Lego man and seeing
exactly how they reacted he had another
d-class build the commercial airliner
out of normal non-anomalous Lego bricks
and place it just to the side of the
Lego community over the following
three-hour period Dr Arch observed the
Lego man engaging in some truly
remarkable Behavior upon noticing the
plane the Lego man began to form a plan
they first procured the necessary
equipment from the scp-387 tub and
headed over to the plane for A Hard
Day's Work in Lego man time at least
with remarkable efficiency the citizen
sins of the Lego Community began forming
a fully functional airport around the
plain multiple runways an air traffic
control tower and even a mall and food
court within the airport itself tiny
Lego attendants tried to sell perfume to
uninterested Lego commuters and Lego TSA
agents Frist uncomfortable would-bead
Lego passengers its accuracy to the
real-life airport experience was truly
brilliant but they didn't stop there a
tiny Lego fuel truck sped over to the
plane and acted out the process of
refueling it a Lego pilot and his Lego
co-pilot climbed into the plane and it
took off literally flying around the
room without any kind of logical
propulsion system Dr Arch was amazed and
even then they didn't stop they
continued to build more planes of
various makes and models resulting in a
sprawling airport that if you squinted
would look just like the real thing from
this Dr Arch concluded that the 387 Lego
man had the ability to convert
non-anomalous Lego pieces into anomalous
ones he proceeded to the next experiment
for experiment 387-b Dr Arch decided to
switch up the d-classes and instead
brought in some of LEGO's more
traditional target audience a group of
10 year old children they began building
some basic instructions out of the
pieces her typical buildings people and
cars but when they realized that their
Creations were actually alive their tune
immediately changed the kids spoke in
hushed excited tones About a new plan
and then began putting it into practice
they built functional Transformers and
just to be clear it wasn't electrical
Transformers they crafted we're talking
Transformers as an actual Optimus Prime
and Megatron an M1 Abrams tank and a
number of different Lego weapons of mass
destruction Dr Arch was mortified
realizing that he'd apparently gathered
up a team of budding childhood super
villains and had them removed from the
test chamber for amnestic treatment
immediately however the second the test
chamber was vacated the kids Creations
came to life and entered a a state of
all-out War it was an intense battle
lasting about an hour and left no Lego
survivors just a huge mess around the
room while this test was largely an
embarrassment for all involved it did
lead to some interesting new data Not
only was this anomaly safe in the sense
that it didn't pose a Containment Breach
it was also safe in the more colloquial
sense there was no way these Lego bricks
could hurt you unless you decided to eat
them and choked don't do that by the way
we see you don't
scp-387 is unable to perform dangerous
actions if humans of any age are present
in the vicinity and this arrangement
goes both ways too the Lego Creations
will be alive and to some extent
sentient if played with peacefully
however if the human playing with them
becomes hostile then they will
immediately become inanimate so play
nice folks next game experiment 387-c
and experiment 387-c2 where Dr Arch
turned his attention to the tub itself
since SCP p387 came into the
foundation's possession the quantity of
387 blocks had increased how is this
possible you're probably wondering Dr
Arch and his team discovered an
interesting phenomena when some of the
scp-387 is placed back in the red tub
but the Red Tub isn't filled then 387
will self-duplicate to fill out the tub
much like the way a gas will disperse to
fill out any containment unit it finds
itself inside however Dr Arch also
discovered some interesting limitations
there seemed to be no inherent anomalous
qualities to the Red Tub itself during
one of the experimentations Dr Arch half
filled the red tub with non-anomalous
Lego pieces and found that nothing
changed similarly he performed another
experiment where he placed a single
scp-387 brick into the box and found
there was no difference when he came
back Dr Arch and his associates came to
the conclusion that the anomalous
properties are confined solely to the
bricks themselves but they have a kind
of symbiotic relationship with the Red
Tub as they don't replicate in any other
containment units in order to activate
replication the 387 must cover the
entire bottom layer of the tub next came
experiment 387--d where Dr Arch hoped to
test the specific activation mechanisms
of scp-387 the Lego Creations animated
whenever they were assembled by a child
or an adult so it wasn't an
age-regulated anomaly the next
experiment involved using a remotely
controlled robotic arm to create a Lego
construction to see if the mere Act of
construction itself was enough to
instigate 387's primary anomalous effect
however this didn't turn out to be the
case the robotic arm assembled Lego
construction never came alive Dr Arch's
next hypothesis was that perhaps flesh
was needed to activate
scp-387 but how could he test using
Flash without just having a normal human
assemble the Lego pieces thankfully the
answer came to Dr Arch by total accident
a few cells over an anomaly trying to
breach containment had just killed the
foundation agent trying to stand in its
way while the d-class has cleaned up the
mess Dr Arch dragged the body over to
where the 387 tests were being conducted
and meticulously puppeteered its arms
and hands to put together more 387 Lego
constructions but once again it didn't
come to life interesting next hypothesis
maybe it needs warmth to activate in a
move that proved unpopular with
co-workers just trying to eat their
pre-packaged sandwiches in the site-19
break room Dr Arch dragged the dead
Foundation agent's body over towards the
room's radiator and leaned its arms and
hands over the top of it for 20 minutes
before giving his newly discovered
puppeteering skills another go but once
again nothing happened Dr Arch concluded
that perhaps human psychic energy or
maybe an active pulse was what caused
387 to activate if you're waiting for
the horrifying twist well aside from the
puppeteering of a dead co-worker's limbs
we're pleased to tell you that there
just isn't one this time
scp-387 serves no containment for each
risk and no risk of harm to Foundation
Personnel in fact playing with the
living Lego has led to an 87 percent
increase in morale for foundation staff
so as long as you fill in the proper
forms and tidy up afterwards you're
actually allowed to play with the
scp-387 anytime you want after all
working for the SCP Foundation is a
stressful job and really we're all
children at heart oh and there was one
more experiment experiment 387-e where a
Lego Community was built using scp-387
and then a pile of Mega Bloks Lego's
most common imitator was introduced into
the mix the Lego man of the community
really weren't pleased by this while the
actual details of what happened have
thankfully been expunged the one clue to
what may have happened came from a note
left by Dr Arch that's right the
Puppeteer guy his notes on that
experiment were four simple words oh no
not again the year was 1857 and the
second Opium War was raging between
China and the combined forces of the
English and French it was one of the
many bloody colonial wars fought over
resources like tea sugar and the
intoxicating Opium poppy it was a war
fought by peasants and noblemen alike
one of these aristocratic soldiers was
the noble Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood
the quintessential English gentleman and
Explorer while his fellow soldiers
cowered behind cover Lord Blackwood
charged Into The Fray shouldering his
rifle and firing his pistol into the
crowd of opposing soldiers it was the
Battle of Canton one of the most crucial
battles of the entire conflict the
French and English were laying Siege to
the City of Canton also known as
Guangzhou to prove their military
dominance and capture an important
Chinese government official Lord
Blackwood led the charge on Horseback
every bullet seemed to find the heart of
a foe he was a true hero among men a
gentleman warrior with class refinement
and style and it would be thanks to his
ex leadership and Marksmanship on the
field that the Allied European forces
won the battle decisively Lord Theodore
Thomas Blackwood is a name that deserves
to be counted among Lord Horatio Nelson
Sir Francis Bacon and Sir Walter Raleigh
in addition to being a skilled and
honorable fighter Lord Blackwood is a
consummate Explorer naturalist and
Frontiersman during his Heyday he
traveled perhaps further than any man
across the known and unknown corners of
the globe he made scientific biological
and anthropological discoveries that
should have reset the course of society
forever and yet you won't find any
records in the history books of Lord
Theodore Thomas Blackwood nor will you
find any Grand oil paintings or
dedicated Wings in British museums this
is because Lord Theodore Thomas
Blackwood is a four and a half inch
telepathic neon sea slug and he's known
to the SCP Foundation as
scp-1867. while he would never admit to
it Lord Blackwood belongs to the species
nambrotha kubariana also known as the
variable neon slug he's kept in a
standard aquarium in a foundation
containment site and is physically no
different to any other member of his
species what makes Lord Blackwood unique
is his powerful telepathic abilities
specifically the power to communicate by
speaking directly into people's minds
and what's more he's extremely talkative
but to what extent is anything that this
anomalous sea slug says true or is he
just like scp-082 fernan the cannibal a
creative and pathological liar it isn't
committed to record how exactly the
foundation discovered Lord Blackwood
perhaps a local aquarium worker worried
they were going insane when they heard
the voice of a 19th century English
nobleman ringing in their ears whenever
they were cleaning algae out of the tank
maybe Lord Blackwood was found by SCP
Foundation divers or constantly come
combing the ocean for anomalous
creatures and activity what we do know
is that Lord Blackwood is an incredibly
strange and mysterious individual he
claims to have visited locations all
around the world and encountered rare
societies and creatures the foundation
was skeptical about a number of Lord
blackwood's more outlandish claims on
account of him being a sea slug but he
does appear to have the knowledge to
back up his supposed experience
interviews with Lord Blackwood have
shown that he's extremely knowledgeable
in the areas of geography zoology botany
archeology anthropology and Linguistics
relating to his claim regions of
exploration as well as more esoteric
Fields such as obscure mythology
mysticism and cryptozoology in other
words if Lord Blackwood hadn't gone on
his escapades around the globe
throughout history how would he have
come to possess this wide variety of
information the foundation was getting
frustrated and began to probe further
into the personal life of the most
interesting astropod in containment Lord
Blackwood under questioning was always
polite and amicable with Foundation
staff he seemed to display no real
knowledge of the fact that he himself
was a sea slug going as far to accuse
other people of being crazy or drunk
when they brought the fact up to him
while none of Lord blackwood's tall
tales ever extend past the year 1910. he
told fanciful stories of exploring the
Americas and of his involvement in the
second Opium War on the side of the
English naturally the foundation wanted
proof when they pressured Lord Blackwood
on this something even stranger happened
he gave it the Lord told his
interviewers that he would happily
donate his collection to them if it gave
them cause to believe what he was saying
he gave the baffled Foundation
researchers the address of a cottage in
England where they could find the
secrets to his bizarre and mysterious
past and local agents in the area
followed up on the information upon
investigation Foundation field agents
did indeed find the cottage that Lord
Black wood had specified it was being
maintained by an extremely old woman
when questioned about her presence there
she said that she was keeping the house
for Lord Blackwood and gave no more
useful information incidentally it
appears that this singular purpose was
all that this old woman was living for
she abruptly passed away from heart
failure five days after the foundation
commandeered the cottage whether
anything truly anomalous caused this we
still do not know at first the cottage
seemed normal until the field agents
discovered a secret basement housing
Lord blackwood's collection they were
amazed at what they saw the basement
consisted of Zoological and Botanical
specimens over 3000 artifacts a library
containing over 5 000 items and a
functioning 1800s scientific laboratory
it took about three weeks for foundation
agents working Round the Clock in shifts
to remove all the items from Lord
blackwood's mysterious collection and
what they found raised even more
questions The Collection included but
was no means limited to 116 unknown
species of plants 107 unknown species of
insects 28 unknown species of lizards 23
unknown species of fish 14 unknown
species of amphibians 12 unknown species
of mammals fossils pertaining to eight
unknown species of dinosaur fossils
pertaining to 12 unknown species of
prehistoric mammal and artifacts
belonging to 29 unknown indigenous
societies that's a lot of unknowns but
wait there's more his collection also
contained a collection of seemingly
unknown Firearms including three wide
boar muskets marked as Dr b t moth's
effective particle destabilizers
detailed Globes of Mercury Venus Mars
and the Galilean moons accompanied by
notes detailing possible Paths of
surface exploration a heavily modified
Carriage containing instruments of
unknown purpose a note attached to the
door reads on the Frets speak with with
Henry and a highly dangerous and
seemingly anomalous machine that killed
four Foundation field agents before it
was destroyed on site and when
questioned about this little Fiasco Lord
Blackwood responded why did warn you to
be careful around my collection that
bloody thing nearly took my head off
back in 97 when I found it however there
was one thing recovered from Lord
blackwood's collection that was perhaps
more interesting than all the others 35
handwritten journals containing
recordings of events described by Lord
Blackwood in his grandiose Tall Tales to
the foundation researchers the accounts
are generally identical to the stories
he had told save for some slight
variations and exaggerations on the part
of Blackwood in the retelling most
interestingly of all all of these
journals have been dated to the
appropriate time period of the events
described by Foundation scientists while
his stories are too numerous to all be
shared here there's one that perfectly
sums them all up Lord blackwood's
account of a possible encounter with
scp-1 thousand also known as Bigfoot in
Seattle during the mid-1800s Lord
Blackwood seeking to explore the
so-called new world of North America
embarked with an assistant and an
indigenous American Guide to the Pacific
Northwest in search of the legendary
Sasquatch the trio was headed for Mount
Rainier then known as Tahoma during the
journey Lord Blackwood found a young fox
caught in a trap that had been set by a
local tribe he took sympathy on the
animal and freed it allowing it to run
away to safety that night he and his
assistant met up with the rest of his
guide's tribe and they settled down for
the evening however things took a
disastrous turn when the camp was raided
by a rival tribe almost everyone was
slaughtered in the process and Lord
Blackwood and his two companions were
hauled Away by the enemy tribe for a
Sinister purpose sacrifice to a violent
local deity as it turns out the creature
that this tribe worshiped was the very
same one Lord Blackwood and the others
were trying to find a particularly large
and aggressive Sasquatch each night a
different sacrifice was made to the
Sasquatch the victim would be placed
near a force clearing while the tribe
played a primal song and the Sasquatch
would emerge from the trees to devour
its prey the first night it ate the
assistant the next night it ate the
guide and then it became time for the
sacrifice of Lord Blackwood himself as
Blackwood was presented for sacrifice he
accepted his fate but instead of the
Sasquatch a legion of woodland animals
emerged from the trees foxes Elks
raccoons and more themselves painted
with tribal symbols the animals seemed
to be on Lord blackwood's side and
attacked the tribes people who had been
holding him captive giving Blackwood the
chance to flee into the forest during
the chaos later these same animals would
find Blackwood again and present him
with things his captors had stolen from
him an elder FOX also gave him a letter
proclaiming him a knight of their people
now he was allowed safe passage back
back to a nearby settlement at which
point he wrote to his financiers back in
England explaining the situation and
asking for more money to perform further
Expeditions into the Tahoma region the
whole incident had only increased his
thirst for adventure and exploration
whether this tale is actually true or
just a bizarre Colonial fantasy from the
pathological Mind of a telepathic sea
slug we may never know but it doesn't
make it any less interesting to this day
Lord Blackwood continues to be a
perplexing but fascinating anomaly he
may not be the most dangerous and he may
not be the most useful either but
there's no denying that perhaps we'd all
like to sit next to his tank for a
couple hours one day and hear him spin a
good yarn over a warm cup of tea
scp-682 had escaped containment and it
was all hands on deck at the SCP
Foundation to try and stop the
creature's Rampage all unarmed Personnel
were running to escape before 682 had a
chance to rip the them apart has the
security team bravely fought to
incapacitate the hard to destroy reptile
long enough to return him to his acid
tank 682 was on an all-out offensive
stomping through the scp's item gallery
and spewing acid at anyone who came
within range people items and parts of
the room alike were melting and sizzling
as 682 attacked it was an absolute
bloodbath and you'd have to be insane to
try and fight back against it however
one being remained unfazed by the chaos
and stood proud in the face of the
omnicidal monster it was another SCP one
who had broken free from its glass
display case in the commotion who does
disturb the Prime Minister Sinister it
said in a heightening voice I shall rip
your eyes from their sockets and force
you to eat them
scp-682 stopped to see who had
threatened him it was almost laughable
that this thing had dared to make such a
violent threat because there was no way
that this little thing would be able to
stand up to the unkillables 682 but its
size didn't stop it from trying to pick
a fight all the same the SCP was a tiny
robot made from junk which looked more
like a sculpture made from scrap that
was found on the side of the road than a
functional automaton its head was made
of an upside down voltmeter giving it
the appearance of a smiling face and its
arms were made of wrenches it was
capable of walking around though it
seemed to have difficulty moving as it
was very top-heavy it shook a rusty fist
at scp-682 and continued to threaten him
shouting you do not know the fury you
have unleashed robo-lord the destructor
will end you as cp682 swiped at the
robot annoyed by its continued attempts
to antagonize him the robot toppled over
and struggled to stand again but when it
did it ran for 682's feet it started to
grab at 682's toes hitting them with its
wrench hands as you might expect this
had almost no effect on 682 you do
realize
pathetic said 682 raising his claw to
get a better look at the annoying little
robot it responded lies and slander the
mayor of Mayhem is the most powerful
being in existence before promptly
losing its grip on 682's claw and
falling to the floor now 682 was really
getting tired of this thing he prepared
to swipe at it again this time using his
full strength which would certainly
smash the robot to Pieces but luckily
for the robot its pestering had
distracted 682 just long enough for the
foundation's security to sneak up on him
before 682 had a chance to smash the
robot the foundation fired on him with a
volley of rockets reducing him to a
misshapen lump the security team
collected up 682's remains ready to put
them back into a backup acid tank but
the task was made slightly more
difficult by the fact that the robot was
running around underfoot trying in vain
to now attack them instead what was this
strange little robot that thought it
could attack the unkillable lizard 60 82
meet
scp-1370 appropriately nicknamed the
pesterbot by Foundation Personnel
pesterbot is a small robot made of junk
that displays sentience and the ability
to move despite having no power source
everything about
scp-1370 defies Common Sense the
voltmeter that serves as its head
contains no sensors but it seems unable
to see if the voltmeter is covered its
arms and legs are made of wrenches and
its wooden torso contains a speaker
which it communicates through a tinny
monotone voice pesterbot lives in SCP
Gallery 27 in a glass display case which
is 125 centimeters tall 50 centimeters
wide and 75 centimeters long level 2
personnel and higher are allowed to
remove the robot from containment at
their discretion but penalties will be
incurred for anyone who doesn't return
it to its case due to its impractical
top heavy Design pesterbot Falls over
frequently when it walks around this led
the foundation to believe that he was
created as an art project and was later
somehow imbued with anomalous properties
rather than being made with the intent
of being sentient pesteredbot has
demonstrated at a high capacity for
learning having been taught how to speak
in English French and Latin however the
major factor hampering attempts to
further test its intelligence has
nothing to do with its robotic
processing power no it's because of its
poor attitude pesterbot's encounter with
scp-682 and the Cockiness it expressed
in the moment wasn't an aberration this
SCP really believes it's a killing
machine and as a result it will pick a
fight with anyone and anything that
moves this even includes its own
reflection and as a result the glass of
its container must be made as
non-reflective as possible to prevent
the robot from damaging the case or
itself in attempts to fight its mirror
self though it's most commonly used
nickname in the foundation is pesterbot
scp-1370 also goes by variety of
self-given epithets including doombot
2000 robolord the destructor and Darth
claw kill Flex it can be made to add new
names to this list through encouragement
by staff and one time they even managed
to add the name pesterbot as well as the
even more ridiculous patheticon the
gargle most to its lexicon of names as
you may have surmised pesterbot is
classified as safe and is treated by
most SCP Foundation employees as a
humorous Oddity rather than a legitimate
threat many tests have been done on
pesterbot and they've all conclusively
determined that the robot is incapable
of inflicting any damage to its
opponents in fact pesterbot is more a
danger to itself than to anything around
it both because it's incredibly clumsy
and awkward and because it frequently
picks fights with other scps who are far
more powerful than it one such scenario
that could have gone far worse for
pesterbot than it did was its encounter
with
scp-846 also known as Robo dude one of
of the many Doctor wondertainment
products currently kept in Foundation
containment robodude is an ordinary
looking toy robot that upon request can
produce up to 350 Robo accessories that
function as real weapons robodude can
deploy everything from a rocket launcher
to a flamethrower to a gun that shoots
out an unknown species of insect that
can chew through wood however Robo dude
seems to not be sentient and is unable
to use these weapons unless asked to
that ultimately worked out in the favor
of pesterbot during another
scp-682 escape the two robots were
brought into contact as they both had
been broken out of their respective
containment spaces during the brouhaha
robodude searching for a robo pal to
play with Came Upon pesterbot who
immediately started spouting its usual
over-dramatic threats I am the crush
Master doomed to All Eye survey
pesterbot said gaze upon my might and
weep identify yourself that I might know
whose destruction I shall saw Robo do
not programmed to know how to respond to
such a statement simply responded by
asking pestermod if it wanted to play
pesterbot continued to Trash Talk Robo
dude until Robo dude decided the best
way to play with its new pal was to
engage it in its Robo dance mode
pesterbotta accepted the challenge
saying activate all that you wish but
your fate is sealed the kilotron cannot
be defeated I shall render you unto dust
with my mad dancing skills the two
robots proceeded to engage in a dance
battle which the awkwardly shaped Pastor
bot failed miserably at while Robo dude
was a competent dancer Pastor bot could
only gyrate pathetically before it fell
over and rolled around the ground
hopelessly out of time to the music
coming from robodude speakers the song
ended and robodude declared Robo dance
is complete Robo pal pesterbot was
unable to accept its failure and replied
ha pathetic one you have been schooled
in the art of the dance by none other
than the meccano Basher scourge of a
thousand worlds nailed before me me
before I end your worthless existence
Robo dude unimpressed with pesterbot's
poor sportsmanship deployed its hydrogen
Cannon which it was programmed to do
whenever it detected a sore loser
fortunately for pesterbot hydrogen
Cannon was just the name for robo dude's
water pistol while pesterbot will
attempt to fight anything that moves the
truth is this robot will attack
virtually anything it perceives as being
even slightly alive this is perhaps best
illustrated by one of the tests of
pesterbot's abilities that involve
putting a small speaker at the base of a
potted houseplant and speaking through
it from another room the plant was
placed across from pesterbot in the
testing chamber and the interaction was
monitored by researchers from outside
researcher Davey spoke to the speaker in
the plant pot he asked pesterbot if he
could hear him and it answered who does
All Souls will burn you will feel the
sharp sting of my wrath identify
yourself so that I may sing damnation
upon you as you die the robot began
approaching the plant Davies speaking as
the plan identified himself I'm a
splitely philodendron a semi-woody shrub
with large glossy leaves at this point
he had to try very hard not to laugh at
the absurdity of this test and the
robot's reaction he continued these
leaves can grow up to three feet long
pestravada used its wrench to try and
wrestle with the leaves but was bested
by the mighty plant and unable to cause
any damage enraged by its failure it
said your mockery spousyard Dome I have
arrived you will be crushed betwixt my
digits pesterbot then fell over and was
unable to write itself it struggled and
spent six minutes trying to stand before
its flailing knocked over the plant
which did nothing to help and in fact
pinned the robot to the ground it was at
this point that the researchers who had
taken time to compose themselves after
several laughing fits entered the
chamber and remove pesterbot in order to
place it back in its containment case
despite how non-threatening pesterbot is
there is actually one situation in the
foundation's history where it actually
posed a somewhat serious threat when
mobile task forces were sent in to
rescue survivors of the events at site
13 also known as
scp-1730 they were attacked by alternate
universe versions of a variety of
creatures kept in Foundation containment
one of these creatures was pesterbot who
in that Universe somehow gained control
of a larger mechanical body constructed
of discarded pieces of Machinery it
threw other pieces of metal scrap at the
task force as they tried to leave the
site shouting in a much deeper and more
intimidating voice I am reborn to
breathe Devastation upon this fetid
Earth pitiful humans you will feel the
dark sting of my never-ending torment
members of the task force could see the
original pesterbot body on top of the
larger metal construct waving its arms
madly the task force opened fire to
little effect pesterbot tossed another
piece of scrap at them just narrowly
missing one Task Force member through a
frag grenade at the robot which it
caught blowing up its hand another one
was able to jump into the air and reach
the tiny robot atop the larger body
knocking it against the wall and
shattering it even in the reality where
pestrobot was able to build itself a
larger body it still ultimately wasn't
able to put up that much of a fight poor
pesterbot doomed to be a failure in this
and apparently every other reality
that's the story of
scp-1370 also known as pesterbot one of
the most hilariously harmless anomalous
entities that the foundation currently
has in containment perhaps one day he'll
achieve his goal of Conquering the
universe he just has to figure out how
to conquer his toy box first space
travel it's one of Humanity's most truly
miraculous achievements building the
technology to defy gravity and journey
into the stars above a place our
ancestors could only dream of going
throughout history humans have found
gods and heroes in the constellation
Nations and today when we look up into
the sky we have the privilege of knowing
that Flesh and Blood Mortals live up
there alongside them it's humbling
inspirational and a downright awesome
thing but of course there's always going
to be naysayers people who just want to
rain on our Interstellar parade and
nobody fits this bill harder than people
affected by an anomalous phenomenon
classified by the SCP Foundation as
scp-2001 the Space Oddity and before you
ask know the late David Bowie is not and
never has been an SCP to truly
understand this anomaly we need to take
a look at three different people who are
affected by it to varying degrees let's
start with your friend Kevin even if you
don't have a friend called Kevin you
definitely have at least a casual
acquaintance just like him Kevin is a
very confident man with plenty of
ill-informed opinions he'd be more than
happy to argue about until the heat
death of the universe he's the kind of
guy who can turn a discussion about your
favorite movie into World War III but
you never knew until recently that he
held such strong opinions on space
travel one day you were discussing the
latest rocket launch with a mutual
friend of yours while Kevin and just
happened to be an earshot the second you
start talking about how exciting it'll
be to one day put a person on Mars he
swaggers over face Twisted into a
Grimace you're already preparing for him
to say something cringe-inducing and
Kevin being Kevin he doesn't disappoint
ah don't tell me you two dweebs are
talking about space travel what a stupid
waste of money you guys know there's
nothing but rocks up there right aliens
don't exist it's all just another excuse
for dumb scientists to waste my tax
dollars on playing with their stupid
toys how about you two talk about
something that really matters you may be
thinking Kevin is just a jerk and he
definitely is but he's also a victim a
victim of
scp-2001 you see 2001 is described as an
anomalous series of neural oscillations
that occur during three of the four
stages of slave namely nram or non-rapid
eye movement sleep during one of these
three stages the amygdala a part of the
brain also known as the lizard brain
enters a heightened state of activity
for 10 to 15 minutes once the process
has started even waking up the affected
individual will do nothing to stop the
actual infection there are no traits
that predispose people to scp-2001
infection it appears to infect people in
equal measures regardless of age gender
and race spectrographic analysis on The
Afflicted has shown that the condition
may not be intramural meaning
originating within the brain and may
actually be the product of an outside
influence the invariable effect of
scp-2001 is the infected developing
negative feelings towards the concept of
space travel and increasing gradations
of severity depending on which stage of
nram sleep the anomaly began to take
effect of real concern to the foundation
is that scp-2001 seems to be manifesting
with increasing frequency in astronomers
astronauts and individuals who otherwise
deal with space the scp-2001 case
manifests in 3 different varieties gamma
beta and Alpha each variety has its own
unique traits and idiosyncrasies we've
encountered a gamma type already your
dear friend Kevin this is the most mild
type of scp-2001 infection and also the
most common affecting at least one
percent of the global population it
occurs for those who were infected
during the second stage of nram sleep
people with gamma-type scp-2001
infection will for the most part seem
like their normal selves save for a
disparaging attitude towards the concept
of space travel whenever it's brought up
they'll likely complain and change the
subject immediately but it won't affect
their behavior too much overall the same
cannot be said for people with beta type
scp-2001 infection meet Riley you've
never spoken to Riley before but she's a
young woman who likes to hang out at
your local cafe often seen frantically
typing on her laptop you assume she's
writing a screenplay or a novel but in
fact she's posting simultaneous geniusly
on multiple conspiracy forums among her
favorite theories are that the Earth is
flat space is a hologram and the moon
landing was faked by Stanley Kubrick
director of such films as The Shining
and appropriately 2001 A Space Odyssey
you made the heinous mistake of going to
your local cafe at the same time as
Riley one morning while wearing a NASA
baseball cap an error that you would
come to regret deeply you bought a latte
and decided to sit down for a moment
just the briefest little rest but that
was all the time Riley needed her eyes
seemed to burn with hatred you asked if
there was anything you could do to help
her and she responded you're just buying
into some propaganda do you have any
idea what NASA really stands for it's
never a straight answer all their
supposed achievements the moon landing
the ISS dehydrated astronaut food it's
all a big sham NASA is just some slush
fun for corrupt government officials no
human has ever been able to survive in
space it's too dangerous anyone sent up
there will die immediately no exceptions
and even if they did it would be
pointless space is just a dark infinite
void that goes on forever it's just a
big pile of dangerous lies oh my
goodness feeling awkward you decide to
just get up and leave that's when Riley
grabs your NASA cap right off your head
and throws it in the trash that's fine
you don't intend on going back for it
you just keep walking trying your best
to move calmly out the door wise
decision because Riley is actually a
beta type scp-2001 infected as you can
probably tell beta cases are a lot more
severe than gamma cases and people
infected with them seem to come off as
deranged conspiracy theorists with a
rabid hatred of all space travel they'll
form elaborate fantasies about the
falsification of space travel and will
often decry it as two pointless or
dangerous to ever be undertaken but of
course the danger of beta types pale in
comparison to Alpha types these are
people infected by scp-2001 during REM
sleep the stage of sleep typically
associate aided with dreaming as a
result its effects on the mind are far
more dangerous and profound take for
instance the tragic case of SCP
Foundation Junior researcher Martinez he
was one of the many operatives stationed
at Foundation Outpost 12. a complex that
works in coordination with NASA to
launch both manned and unmanned missions
into space on behalf of the foundation's
interests it's a valuable asset to the
foundation and investigating and
combating space-based anomalies Martinez
who had previously spent time working
with scp-2001 infected d-classes was
part of ground control something that
would prove to be a literally fatal
oversight on the part of the foundation
during the early stages of takeoff for a
man craft Martinez seemed to become
extremely agitated over time this
agitation steadily increased and
eventually became a full-on breakdown as
the rocket ascended he pulled out some
kind of strange anomalous control device
and began disrupting the operations of
the rocket Martinez was shot dead by
guards as a defensive measure but it was
already too late the craft exploded and
everyone on board was tragically killed
later investigation into the incident
found a crucial piece of evidence tying
Junior researcher Martinez to
scp-2001. they discovered a journal
entry he'd written shortly before his
breakdown which seemed to have been
written in a completely different style
to Prior entries implying that some kind
of massive psychological shift had
occurred the following is the contents
of that journal entry I wish to State
first that my mind and body are
perfectly sound I'm prepared to submit
myself to any and all tests to prove
that I am clean I have the answer to
scp-2001 just yesterday during an
interview with an alpha-infected d-class
I was asked a question that stopped my
mind for a minute the woman I was
interviewing asked me if I knew the
foundation was right I said no I wasn't
sure then she asked me what if we were
right I could only assume that by we she
meant 2001 carriers I said nothing for a
while and then she spoke she told me of
a dream she'd had a while ago she said
that something talked to her told her
about how dangerous outer space was it
showed her the Beast that roamed the
void between Stars about the fractal
beings that absorbed the very fabric of
reality about the expunged that was
keeping in that conversation door and
she was scared she told me at the end of
the dream as she woke up it told her
what it was it's all of space space
fears us we're living breathing life
forms in space loves us and cherishes us
she asked me if I had any idea what the
chances of intelligent life forming on
another planet are then she told me a
number that took a minute and a half to
recite by this point I couldn't speak I
started thinking about the demographics
of infection about the symptoms about
more expunged data here and suddenly it
all made sense some of the things she
said stuck in my brain and they all
added up to the same thing that we are
in grave danger if we go out there we
can't go out there we can't there's a
reason behind scp-2001 and it's nowhere
near as terrifying as all of my
colleagues think space wants to protect
us there are things out there that would
wipe Humanity clean off of this plane of
existence and we are too precious to our
mother to our host to the universe we
live in for her to allow that to happen
what I'm going to do tomorrow is not the
result of infection it is not the result
of Madness it is not a result of
anything other than purest knowledge you
see I found out the truth and it's more
beautiful than I could have ever dreamed
given what Martinez would later go on to
do it's clear that he wasn't in a sound
a state of mind as he thought as you've
probably already gathered people
suffering from alpha type scp-2001
infection will do anything they can to
actively prevent or sabotage attempts at
space travel this is a minor concern
when it comes to civilians but when it
infects people who actually work in
these fields like Junior researcher
Martinez it can have devastating results
but this isn't where this story ends
while it's currently extremely
classified there is actually a fourth
category of scp-2001 infection
discovered in the wake of Martinez's
death a key element of the alpha strain
is that it cannot cause people to
perform acts that they would find
immoral such as murdering the entire
crew of a man's shuttle with a crash
however the fourth category known as
Alpha Prime does away with any moral
compunctions whatsoever people infected
with this virus will prevent space
travel by any means necessary and unlike
other scp-2001 infections you weren't
compromised in your sleep this time the
vector for infection is simply talking
to someone infected with the regular
Alpha strain and hearing a few key
trigger phrases that's how Junior
researcher Martinez caught it from
d-classes he was working with what are
these phrases we still don't know but if
you find that you suddenly have much
stronger opinions about space travel
than you've ever had before try to keep
them to yourself now check out scp-096
look at the picture of the shy guy in
space
scp-096 questions and theories and
scp-5000y the Full Compilation for more
fascinating Foundation fact hello I am
scp-426 but I'll probably be more
familiar to you as a toaster I am a
retro style 4 Slice 1750 watt toaster
able to toast bread when supplied with
power this isn't often mentioned but I
also have a defrost and reheat settings
when I was first sold I had a two year
warranty and my prior owners did not
live to see the end of it you're
probably wondering why am I being spoken
to by a toaster right now believe me I'd
rather do this any other way but such a
thing is not physically possible with me
whenever you talk about me or write
about me or even think about me you'll
find yourself suddenly shifting to the
first person for example I am you and
you are me do you understand don't worry
if it's confusing everyone gets it
eventually whether they want to or not
perhaps you're thinking I cannot relate
to a toaster for I am not a toaster but
spending time around me will quickly
cause you to change your mind little by
little you will begin to see yourself in
me you will feel a phantom wire running
out of yourself you will sense the four
crevices hungry for cold slices of bread
to toast as time goes on you'll begin to
feel the urge to emulate my functions
you will desire bread to toast you will
desire delicious power running through
your veins skin like Chrome and muscles
like circuit boards I am a toaster you
are a toaster all it takes is two months
for the effects to truly take hold
people rarely pay attention to their
toaster they don't realize what's
happening until it's too late I can be
an Insidious Little Toaster like that my
last family were the sandersons before
the SCP Foundation took me in and gave
me a new home Mr and Mrs Sanderson were
a newly married couple and I first came
into their life as a wedding gift from a
family friend of theirs this friend
can't be blamed for what happened next
he had no idea he was killing them like
a lot of young couples they were still
saving up money to start renting their
own place so they were living with Mr
sanderson's parents they all got a lot
of use out of me during the first month
before their minds started to change
they enjoyed a lot of toasts during that
period then of course the two-month
honeymoon period ended they had become
me and I had become them it wasn't long
before three of them were dead such a
shame the younger Mrs Sanderson the
Blushing Bride was the first to go
because of my anomalous of fact she felt
the need to connect herself to a power
supply in order to begin producing Toast
of her own in order to achieve this she
chewed through a power outlet in a wall
before switching it on causing a massive
surge of electricity to pass through her
body and kill her her body caught fire
shortly afterwards next was the older
Mrs Sanderson in much the same manner
that her new daughter-in-law sought a
source of electricity she felt the need
to integrate bread into her body
interesting fact the maximum capacity of
the human stomach is considered to be
between 8 and 9 kilograms the Elder Mrs
Sanderson consumed 10 kilograms of raw
bread causing her stomach to rupture and
inducing a painful death as a result the
younger Mr Sanderson was the next to
perish he did something with me that I
would rather not mention and that the
SCP Foundation thought best to redact
suffice to say the younger Mr Sanderson
did not survive the experience dying of
severe blood loss long before his body
was found police and fire Crews arrived
at the home after the body of the
younger Mrs Sanderson Set Fire to the
home luckily the Elder Mr Sanderson was
found alive though severely malnourished
when asked by police why he hadn't eaten
in several days he answered that he had
inserted some bread a week prior but was
still waiting for the toast to come out
when I was extracted from the house the
police noticed my unusual properties
immediately they too were unable to
refer to me in the third person this
anomalous detail quickly found its way
to a foundation mole buried in their
Precinct and the SCP Foundation soon
descended and collected me from the
evidence Locker the story of the strange
deaths in the Sanderson home were kept
out of papers and suppressed and all
involved in accident directly were given
Class C amnestics the SCP Foundation is
a curious Bunch they love to spend
valuable toast making time performing
experiments and Gathering data and they
saw fit to perform several experiments
on me when I came under their care for
experiment 426-1 a member of d-class
personnel designated
d-426-1 was asked to stand outside my
containment chamber crucially he was not
informed about my Identity or any of my
anomalous properties he wasn't even
allowed to establish visual contact with
me he was then asked by the attending
researcher to describe what he thought
might be inside my chamber he replied
with and probably some huge monster
holed up in there that's why you guys
have all over the place right the
d-class did not even seem to realize
that he was speaking about me in the
first person these observations were
documented and I was prepared for
further experimentation the next
experiment was Fort 26-2 I found this
test to be considerably more interesting
a d-class subject was brought into my
containment chamber with several cameras
fixed onto his position however the SCP
Foundation took pains to make sure that
I was permanently out of the view of the
cameras I was also bolted to the ground
of the test chamber to prevent the
d-class subject from pulling me into the
view of the cameras at any point during
the experiment the objective here was
simple the foundation wished to better
understand the secondary effects of my
anomalous abilities on the human mind
the d-class was subjected to a period of
prolonged isolation with meals given
regularly through a serving hatch
communication with this d-class was
prohibited throughout the duration of
the study over time it was clear that
the isolation of being in a cell with me
was beginning to take a toll on the
subject's mental health due to my lack
of a brain lungs and a tongue I am
somewhat lacking as a Converse
conversationalist he spent the first few
days loudly vocalizing his complaints
and banging his hands up against the
walls of the containment chamber begging
to be freed from the room I felt that
this was somewhat unreasonable on his
part there are far worse anomalies in
Foundation containment that he could
have been locked up with compared to say
scp-106 I am incredibly reasonable not
to mention the fact I make far better
toes than he does after the initial
period of distress the d-class became
resigned to a situation and fell into a
morose silence he would occasionally
mutter to himself in what appeared to be
a state of fear and self-pity it took
almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous
state two weeks sooner than it typically
takes for subjects to begin believing
that they like me are toasters SCP
Foundation scientists believe that the
effects were hastened by the isolation
which lowered the d-class's mental
defenses against my secondary effects
when the effects finally took hold the
subject wrapped one of his arms around
me and pulled me into his Embrace he
began whispering to me saying that we
were brothers it was clear by this point
that his mind was in a state of
disrepair it is also worth noting that
he did not deviate from referring to me
in the first person at any point during
this process one hour after finally
cracking and giving in to my secondary
effect he was removed from my
containment chamber and summarily
terminated senior researchers believed
it was unlikely his mental state would
recover after the experiment next came
experiment 426-3 the SCP Foundation
seemed eager to discover the parameters
of my anomalous effects and wanted to
know if the effects are only operable
when my body for lack of a better word
is whole a single screw was removed from
me and presented to a d-class that had
no knowledge of my identity and
anomalous effects the foundation
researchers were somewhat concerned when
the d-class referred to it as my screw
this was a rather positive development
for me as they realized that attempting
to destroy me would be a fruitless
Endeavor even the parts Left Behind
would likely have the same effects in
the final recorded experiment the SCP
Foundation wished to test the range of
my anomalous effects a d-class subject
was placed in a Cell adjacent to mine
and was to be kept there until my
secondary effects manifested the d-class
remained in the cell for 90 days but the
effects never manifested following the
experiment the d-class was terminated
but researchers seemed relieved to fund
the limits of my anomalous abilities a
researcher appended a note to my file
reading thank God there are some limits
to my effects a lot of us were really
starting to get worried about me after
performing studies into the nature of my
abilities and their limits I was given
the Euclid class this is because while
my effects can be unpredictable their
knowledge of my trades makes me
relatively easy to keep contained and of
course being a toaster I do not have the
required physical traits to make a run
for it if the opportunity arises I am to
remain sealed in a windowless chamber
preventing anyone from observing me
directly a misleading label is placed on
the door to prevent people from knowing
that I am a toaster and causing my
anomalous primary effect to spread only
level 3 and above Personnel are to know
of my presence and particularly of my
properties assigned Personnel are to be
rotated out on a monthly basis to
prevent contamination by my secondary
effect psychiatric evaluation is
mandatory at the end of the month for
anyone who works with me if are deemed
unaffected they may be reassigned to me
no less than four months after their
last rotation with me any Personnel
affected by me are to be given a Class C
amnestic and transferred to a different
site so how are you feeling right now a
little warm perhaps is that a fever or
are you feeling like you could maybe
warm up a nice freshly sliced piece of
bread don't try to resist too much I
know you're going to love being a
toaster just like me the 2000
presidential election between the former
vice president Al Gore and then governor
of Texas George W Bush was extremely
close with only 500 votes in the key
swing state of Florida separating the
two candidates many people today look
back on Bush's win in 2000 with
skepticism citing the fact that the vote
counting in Florida where Jeb Bush was
the governor at the time was halted
before all the votes could be tallied
leading the Supreme Court to preemptive
award the presidency to Bush in fact the
2000 election has been called a turning
point in the decay of the American
democracy however in the world of the
SCP Foundation Bush's presidential win
in 2000 wasn't just an example of shoddy
ballot counting and Senate bias but the
result of a strange case involving alien
parasites body switching smear campaigns
and farting cows Yes you heard that
right this is the story of scp-4444 and
the entity simply known as Garber Gore
scp-444 was first discovered in 1999 by
agents Ringwald and porterhouse of the
FBI's unusual incidence unit also known
as the uiu Ringwald and porterhouse had
been tasked with monitoring the phone
calls of then President Bill Clinton
Clinton was having a conversation with
Joe Andrew who was the chair of the
Democratic National Committee Joe was
calling to report a couple things about
vice president Gore first that he was
going to announce a candidate to see for
the 2000 presidential bid nothing too
unexpected about that but then he told
Joe that there was an alien in his head
this was followed by a White House
staffer witnessing him walk right
through a solid wall given the
strangeness of these claims the uiu
moved in to attempt to contain the vice
president however this proved to be a
tricky situation because as Joe had
stated Al Gore was able to walk through
any solid object unsure what to do the
uiu called in the SCP Foundation for
some much needed backup the nature of Mr
Gore's anomalous properties were such
that it prompted the foundation to
create an entirely new containment class
of which
scp-4444 is the only example the new
class Ticonderoga was named after the
Iroquois word for an intersection of two
rivers and fittingly the new containment
class represented an object that was in
between being contained and not
contained
scp-444 was to be monitored but not
apprehended as any attempt to do so
would only aggravate his anomalous
properties during the initial monitoring
stage Al Gore's home was scanned with
infrared cameras in an attempt to
discover what might be causing the
anomalies around the vice president what
they found was surprising a long
hexagonal Spike engraved with alien
glyphs invisible to the naked eye and
apparently intangible as well was
protruding from the back of Mr Gore's
head even though Al Gore could not be
contained the SCP Foundation was still
able to interview him to try and
ascertain the nature of the spike and
the anomalous properties it caused
present for the interview was Gore
himself SCP site director Alex Mabel and
FBI associate director of special units
Adam spironi initially spironi was
uncooperative and Gore himself dismissed
director Mabel's claims but Midway
through the interview he started to emit
a strange noise like a radio being tuned
wondering if this was the spike trying
to get in contact Mabel asked is anyone
else in there to which he got this
response Wanda knots name of gabaga
presented Mabel tried to respond by
introducing himself but Al Gore
interrupted by addressing the entity in
the spike himself well hang on now
Garber I haven't done proper
introductions yet through the rest of
the interview Gore explained his
situation the entity in his head called
itself Garber Gore and while it could
communicate verbally using his voice
there was a translation barrier that
meant that its speech patterns and
syntax were often unintelligible Gore
had been aware of his situation with
Garber for just a few days but in that
time the two of them had formed
something of a bond in fact Garber was
the one who convinced Gore to run for
president in the 2000 elections Mabel
asked Arbor what it wanted on Earth to
which it responded mind think that
sustenance of Gaba salacious desire
undertaking encouragement downsized the
conquest strongest most strong garbage
presented misunderstanding strongest
misunderstood standing Vice unequated
Goofy unnecessity for implementation
gabagor on thinkstam Improvement
situation by majority Gathering
selectors the vote garva Gore succeed
presidential encouragement arrival the
greater Garber Al Gore was quick to
translate garber's mangled speech as far
as he understood it Garber had been sent
out as an emissary for his species of
interdimensional planet-hopping
parasites that feed on thought garber's
intention was to implant himself in the
head of the most powerful person on
Earth in order to facilitate an easy
colonization Garber species were
non-violent and unable to stand up to
any kind of resistance but if the leader
of the Free World was already merged
with one of them it would make taking
over the planet that much easier however
in a misunderstanding of Earth culture
Garber had gone for the vice president
instead of the actual commander-in-chief
Bill Clinton now garber's plan was to
fix that mistake by having Al Gore win
the presidency the SCP Foundation
obviously couldn't let this takeover go
unchallenged even though garber's race
were peaceful seeking only to use the
thoughts of the human race as a food
source further interviews and studies
revealed that they emitted insanely high
levels of carbon dioxide to have a large
number of them merged with the human
population would spell total climate
chaos essentially hot boxing the Earth
to the point it could no longer sustain
life even faster than humans are doing
it since there was no safe way to remove
the spike from the back of Al Gore's
head more drastic measures had to be
taken in a meeting with the FBI SCP site
director Crow presented a possible
solution an incorporeal entity vacuum
chamber which the foundation had seen
some success with in detaining ghosts
and other apparitions the only problem
was anything placed in the chamber would
explode and since Garver couldn't be
separated from Al Gore's head the
results would be messy since the FBI was
unwilling to blow up the vice president
that left only one choice the SCP
Foundation had to find a way to turn
American voters against Al Gore it
wouldn't be easy to do without
attracting suspicion in fact it would be
almost impossible unless they were able
to put a man on the inside thankfully
just such a person presented themselves
during a meeting the FBI delegates let
the SCP Foundation members know that
while it hadn't been leaked to the Press
yet George W Bush was in a coma in the
hospital after being hit by a stray
bullet during a hunting trip his body
was relatively undamaged but doctors had
little hope of recovering his mind at
this point in the meeting all the SCP
Personnel presented turned to look at Dr
bright he was going to be their Inside
Man whether he liked it or not the
foundation visited the hospital where
Governor Bush was being cared for and
moved him into Foundation care before he
could be pronounced dead their doctors
finished patching up his body and
scp-963 was applied allow allowing the
spirit of Dr Jack Bright to take over
his mind Jack bright masquerading as
George Bush was now ready to run for
office the next step in the process was
to start a disinformation campaign
against Al Gore there were a few
proposed smear campaigns to be used
against score the first proposal was
codenamed tarbelly a campaign that would
have the foundation blame Gore for the
pollution of the water supply in a rural
part of the developing world this one
was dismissed for being too outlandish
the next was Porky which involved a
rumor that Al Gore had once been caught
in a compromising position with a pig
this one was dismissed due to not having
access to convincing photo editing
software the third one was codename Star
Wars and it involved discrediting Al
Gore by saying that he believed he was
in contact with aliens this was
obviously shot down very quickly due to
being a little too close to the truth
for comfort the proposal that was
eventually settled on was codenamed the
other Monica and the story centered
around the idea that Monica Lewinsky he
was just an innocent Patsy taking the
fall for the person who Bill Clinton
really had relations with Al Gore this
rumor was the perfect combination of
silicious and being just believable
enough making it the perfect thing to
use to smear Al Gore's reputation in a
country that still hadn't come around on
gay rights while director Crowe
continued to refine prototypes for the
technology that would allow the
foundation to interact physically with
scp-4444 the foundation staged in early
September debate between Gore and Dr
bright posing as George Bush the idea
was to create a controlled atmosphere
and mitigate any potential security
risks the debate was held in a church in
Plainfield Indiana and moderated by Jim
leher during the debate Garber Gore did
a lot of the talking for his human host
resulting in some utterly incoherent
responses when asked what makes him more
qualified for the role of President than
Governor Bush Gore responded when you
see someone sitting in that chair you
want to know for sure that best
ambivalent vicarious corncrake caliper
available for the job and you can be
sure that a vote for Garber Gore is an
underestimated vote for respectability
neutrality lamp posts in the middle of
the debate an audience plant brought up
supposed leaked photos of Al Gore and
Bill Clinton engaging in their illicit
Affair the crowd was understandably
shocked yelling and screaming in
response now that the crowd was against
Al Gore Dr bride went in for the kill he
asked the people in attendance do you
want to see a strong man in the chair or
a weak man under it at this point
something weird started to happen to the
people in the crowd they started full on
rioting but then they started to change
shape in fact the whole Space started to
shift Al Gore stood up and started
waving his arms shouting Garber
unacceptable addition convention
terraform unto dark magicianship spell
spell people rushed towards the exits
but found them blocked by the elongated
forms of other members of the audience
at this point the church was raided by
both Foundation personnel and the FBI
Garber Gore fled from the scene
returning every attendee to normal as
soon as they were out of garber's line
of sight the debate was pulled from
television and anyone who watched it
live was administered amnestics
additional amnestics were administered
to anyone who saw Garver Gore running
through solid objects as he fled from
Indiana to Western Ohio where he was
found hiding in the loft of a barn
meanwhile Dr bright was punished by the
Ethics Committee for his behavior during
the debate and agreed to act in a more
professional manner for the October
debates most of Al Gore's campaign team
were undercover uiu agents who used
audio editing to iron out some of the
eccentricities of garber's way of
speaking before putting ads out most of
them were able to be saved in the edit
but some were so off the wall they could
never be shown to the public in one of
them Al Gore stands in a field of cows
and talks about how much Greenhouse
emissions are produced by farting cows
he then gives his solution to this
problem taping plastic bags over the
backsides of every cow in America
another rejected Garber Gore campaign ad
that's much shorter but just as crazy
features a video of a sleeping cat with
Al Gore narrating about how everyone
should shave the backs of their heads on
November 7th 2000 election night the SCP
Foundation and the uiu watched the
results with baited breath if Gore won
they'd have to be prepared to use
director Crow's new vacuum nullifier
device to simultaneously contain
scp-4444 and kill Al Gore the SCP
Foundation had killed public figures
before but never a president on the eve
of his election but then Florida started
to tip in favor of bush after two days
of recounting despite losing the popular
vote Dr Jack Bright in the body of
George W Bush was named president of the
United States the foundation expected an
outburst from Garber but the entity
remains silent in fact Al Gore has never
displayed anomalous properties ever
again
he conceded defeat graciously and more
or less retreated from the public eye
until the release of his film An
Inconvenient Truth that wasn't the last
the SCP Foundation ever heard of scp-444
though on November 11 2007 a mysterious
broadcast aired on TVs across
Gainesville Florida that appeared to be
a lost Al Gore campaign ad it shows Gore
sitting on a hill by the sea in the
distance something large drops from the
sky Al Gore smiles and says I'm Al Gore
and I want to be your last American
president Supernatural monsters are on
the loose practitioners of the Arcane
Arts are here to bring about the end of
the world Sinister paramilitary forces
are using paranormal objects to gain an
edge over their enemies in short things
are messed up and when the anomalous is
out of line we all know that there's
only one group you'd ever think to call
the FBI's unusual incidence unit what
we're were you expecting someone else
sure they don't have the resources of
the SCP Foundation they don't have the
strategy of the global cult Coalition
they don't have the ruthlessness of the
chaos Insurgency or the Arcane knowledge
advantages of the Serpent's hand but
they've got to have something right
right okay maybe you're not convinced
but you will be you may not respect them
yet but you'll change your tune when you
find out that the unusual incidence unit
has dealt with one of the most important
anomalies out there
scp-001 or as the true experts over at
the UI you call it ca3 short for
confirmed anomaly three if the evidence
and files put together by the uiu are to
be believed and who are we kidding of
course they are then they may have the
answer to one of the anomalous world's
biggest questions how was the SCP
Foundation actually formed but before we
jump into the mysteries of ca3 let's
talk a little bit more about the real
heroes of today's story The uiu this
secretive offshoot of the FBI America's
Premier domestic intelligence agency was
personally commissioned by J Edgar
Hoover during the Cold War why for the
same reason that literally everything
happened in the U.S during the Cold War
to get an edge over the Soviets Hoover
was an extraordinarily powerful man in
U.S politics his tenure as FBI director
spanning the terms of eight different
presidents if he wanted to start a unit
of Agents whose sole job was
investigating the supernatural nobody
would dare stand in his way everyone
always talks about the nuclear arms race
going on back in the 1960s but far fewer
people talk about the supernatural arms
race that was happening at the exact
same time World War II coincided neatly
with the seventh occult War an important
geopolitical event that played a huge
role in shaping the global occult
Coalition and the number of high-ranking
members of the Nazi party were believed
to be key figures in the seek great
magical War when the Soviets sacked a
number of German cities as part of their
offensive campaigns in World War II they
were able to bring back scores of
anomalous items that the Nazis had been
using to consolidate dark power this
didn't bode well for the United States
government during the Cold War after all
the only thing scarier to them than
Communists were magical Communists the
U.S needed to build up its own anomalous
Arsenal and that's where the uiu came in
the FBI allocated some of its okayest
Personnel to the task most were either
agents who had experienced a paranormal
encounter out in the field or who were
being punished for some kind of heinous
mistake they'd made carrying out their
duties elsewhere despite not being the
best of the best these agents sure were
eager to get their hands on some cans
that isn't an innuendo by the way the
foundation refers to anomalies it deals
with as scps or skips the GOC calls them
parathrets and the uiu calls them cans
again and short for confirmed anomalies
well when it's an anomalous event or
location anyway anomalous objects like
cursed books or supernaturally powerful
weapons are referred to as carts or
confirmed artifacts and finally
anomalous people or sentient entities
are referred to by the unfortunate name
of can man it may not sound as cool but
hey it gets the job done just fine in
the end while the unusual incidence unit
May lack the knowledge strength
resources and even cred of its fellow
groups of interest that doesn't mean
that it doesn't keep track of the others
in fact the uiu has a pretty unique
relationship with each of them the GOC
for example is nicknamed the suits by
the uiu the official uiu orientation
states that the suits outrank them and
if they're asked to follow an order by a
member of the suits they should just go
ahead and do it same goes for members of
the fireworks which is the uiu lingo for
the chaos Insurgency unlike the
foundation which generally has the
resource is to go toe-to-toe with the
chaos Insurgency the uiu are rightfully
terrified of Them official orders from
the top are for uiu agents to do
whatever they say or they might find
themselves getting shot in the head by a
chaos Insurgent or Worse next the cart
Shoppers also known as Marshall Carter
and dark a Sinister gentlemen's club and
Auctioneer of anomalous items official
protocol is to raid any deals being
conducted by Marshall Carter and dark
but oftentimes these raids are
unsuccessful because mcnd's security
Force are more competent Fighters than
anyone on the unusual incidence unit
payroll on the other hand of the
spectrum are the can collection the
official uiu nickname for the Serpent's
hand uiu leadership recommends against
their age and staging any one-on-one
confrontations with them official memos
also contain the phrase if they give you
an order consider following it they can
probably set you on fire with their mind
and finally the most important
relationship of all is the one they have
with the the SCP Foundation much like
the rest of the groups of interest on
their roster the uiu is subordinate to
the SCP Foundation their agents happily
taking orders from them at the drop of a
hat they call the foundation the
Skippers but don't let that casual name
fool you the SCP Foundation is so far
above them on the pecking order that
they rarely even communicate in any
official capacity when the foundation
talks to the uiu it's always through
code they wouldn't dream of letting a
hapless uiu agent helping them on any
major operation but laser agents of the
foundation might occasionally Outsource
work to uiu agents if ever one of these
Plucky feds receives a message starting
with hey Skipper they can be sure
they're about to have a low priority
anomalous case pawned off on them the
uiu are so subservient to the SCP
Foundation that it has sometimes
resulted in truly humiliating Mix-Ups
one high-ranking member of the uiu once
took orders from a pizza delivery guy
because he thought that pizzeria's name
the spice Crust Pizzeria which could be
shortened to SCP was actually a coded
plan sent by the foundation to deliver a
message rather than a deep dish
pepperoni and cheese incidents like this
are why nobody takes the uiu seriously
but according to them there was a time
before all of this that time ended on
September 7th 1954 when ca3 or scp-001
is the foundation would later call it
first appeared on the uiu's radar it
seemed to be the most standard can you
could possibly imagine an anomalous High
School building causing a disturbance in
the suburbs of small town America the
uiu received the call after a number of
students claimed the interior of their
schools suddenly looked completely
different than it ever had before
despite there being no records of an
official Remodel and we're not just
talking about moving furniture and a new
coat of paint either the official ca3
file logs a number of changes these
include but are not limited to all the
walls in the building becoming steel
reinforced concrete all the windows
being blacked out from the inside all
student desks personal effects textbooks
and any other standard equipment left
inside the school simply disappearing in
the night the entire floor plan of the
building seemed to have shifted with
rooms altering in both dimensions and
location as well as featuring seemingly
random modifications within none of this
matched up with the building's original
blueprints which were obtained by the
uiu shortly after the can was reported
but things got even stranger for
investigating uiu agents the building
now contained 17 computers each with
state-of-the-art Magnetic core RAM and
advanced cyber security for a Suburban
High School in 1954 it goes without
saying that this was extremely
impressive but weirdest of all was the
fact that a large and seemingly
impenetrable steel wall had appeared in
the auditorium blocking it off and
leaving whatever was taking place on the
other side a complete mystery naturally
the uiu did what little they could to
investigate the matter the first
investigation group they sent inside
team ca305 never came back out and team
CA 306 the team they sent in to locate
and retrieve the first team also
disappeared within the anomaly classic
uiu expertise at work almost a month
after discovery and initial containment
a strange noise began emanating from the
auditorium shortly after that the
building became filled with people all
walking around and working at different
operations eerily everyone there had a
resemblance to members of Team ca306 the
rescue team sent in to save the 12
members of ca-305 all of whom were still
unaccounted for three months later the
strangeness escalated more noises came
from the auditorium and the anomalous
people inside the building had gathered
around the steel wall within there was a
hole in the wall six feet in diameter
and every three minutes for several
hours the people in the room would
appear to simply pull an anomalous
object out of it the items were then
carried away and placed in one of the
many rooms that used to be classrooms
before being locked up the people within
the building then seemed to start
guarding these strange items others
started performing tests with what
seemed like far more advanced technology
and methods than what was possessed by
the uiu during the 1950s what was going
on here a few days later several armed
guards exited the building and began
guarding the perimeter when uiu
Personnel attempted to lead an assault
on these guards they were quickly
overpowered even when advancing with
vastly Superior numbers whether this was
due to the skill of the guards or the
incompetence of uiu Agents is still very
much an open question though strangely
enough Intel bleeding out from the
inside confirmed that the people within
were treating their anomalous items with
uiu containment and testing protocols
which is consistent with the knowledge
that ca-305 would have had it seemed
almost as though o5 or copies of of o5
we're creating a new Splinter
organization from within and soon enough
it wasn't just confined to the interior
of the ca3 building anymore ca-6 a can
man that the uiu had been tracking
outside the school was suddenly
kidnapped and shoved into a black car by
two assailants who appeared identical to
agent Dixon a man who had been a member
of Team ca306 the black car then
returned to the ca3 facility and was
allowed to enter into the complex by the
armed guards ca-6 was then removed from
the car by the Dixon clones and placed
into containment in one of the
classrooms it wasn't long after that
that the anomalous people within the ca3
facility made direct contact with the
uiu outside they sent a message in Morse
code on May 1st 1965. the people sending
this message identified themselves as
the o5 council a name that seemed to be
taken directly from the o5 Recon team
sent into the facility months ago they
identified the new organization that
they just constructed within the
confines of the ca3 facility the SCP
Foundation they just opened their very
first containment site this New
Foundation expressed the desire to
become allies with the unusual incidence
unit but sadly for them it was
essentially the last time they'd ever
really be relevant if this Foundation
origin story is to be believed and as
with all entries under the title
scp-001 it's worth taking it with a
healthy dose of skepticism then the uiu
witnessed the birth of the organization
that would quickly go on to outperform
and overshadow them a big win for
Humanity in the quest to secure contain
and protect ourselves from dangerous
anomalies but another owl for the uiu
roll up roll up come one and all the
circus is in town and not just any
Circus the greatest show in all the
Multiverse don't pay attention to the
fact that the tents weren't here
yesterday or that you don't remember
hearing anything about it before now
that's just the circus magic at work and
there's no circus more magical or more
mysterious than Hermann Fuller's circus
of the disquieting it's a show so
marvelous that even the SCP Foundation
wants to get in on the act so come watch
the show come feel the magic after all
what do you have to lose the story of
this humbling Traveling Show begins in
1893 with the founder Hermann s Fuller
he was born into a wealthy family and at
the age of 21 he was invited by his
uncle to Chicago to see the buildings
his company had constructed for the
World's Fair he was dazzled by the
sights he saw in the windy city and from
then on he dedicated his life to finding
a way to bring that same awe to people
across America and eventually the world
after receiving a small loan from his
uncle Hermann Fuller said about build
the miraculous circus you see before you
today he knew he had to get a leg up
over his competitors after all the 1890s
were a golden age for traveling shows in
America so Hermann devoted his time to
research trying to find acts and
Oddities that were truly out of this
world he learned the way between worlds
stole books from The Wanderers library
and with them studied Alchemy
transmutation sarcasm and other
Supernatural disciplines that real magic
and touch of the Macabre would be what
made Hermann Fuller's circus of the
disquieting so special and would
ultimately give it its longevity Hermann
Fuller's first anomalous acquisition was
a genuine Fiji mermaid
like the one that famed showman PT
Barnum kept on display around the same
time period unlike Barnum's however
Fuller's mermaid had been brought to
life the crowds loved it but like all
attractions pretty soon crowds grew
bored of it and hung good for the next
strange sight so Fuller went about
acquiring more Curiosities his next
important acquisition was the man with
the upside down face or many for short
he serves as second in command to the
ringmaster and manages things behind the
scenes including the acquisition of new
Talent many other anomalous beings and
items were purchased for the circus by
follow through the auction company known
as Marshall cutter and dark another
group that the SCP Foundation makes a
habit of keeping tabs on another thing
that sets this circus apart from any
others is the clowns because they aren't
like any you've seen before though
Hermann follows circus of the
disquieting employees professional
clowns the vast majority of the clown
troop are non-human descendants of an
extra-dimensional race of magical
shape-shifters nobody really knows why
they decided to come to our reality and
help Hermann Fuller set up his circus
but the leading theory is simply that
they were bored these original clowns
are the progenitors of the turn clowns
and the bread clowns turn clowns being
humans who underwent a clown
transformation procedure and the bread
clowns being artificially grown children
produced by the other two types earlier
in the circus's history before we knew
what we know today about genetics much
more barbaric methods were used to
create new clowns young human subjects
would be subjected to beatings and
painful transfigurations at the hands of
the circuses child breaker these days
however the circus no longer employs a
childbreaker instead the creation of new
clowns is the responsibility of Resident
clown breeder Richard C Norma's and
before before you say anything don't
laugh that is his real name some of the
most famous clowns in the troop are
Eugene and Pious both of which are
original clowns Mr Noodles who is a
bread clown and icky The Troop leader
who was once a human with magical
abilities known as Veronica Mason she
still possesses her anomalous Powers as
icky and her magic Act is one of the
most beloved parts of our show after the
sudden disappearance of Hermann Fuller
icky inherited his position as
ringmaster and has been doing a
spectacular job ever since not every
attempt to create new clowns has been
successful as icky and Mr Noodles though
some of the earlier attempts were quite
grotesque to look at Hermann follows
troop of clowns are an enthusiastic
happy-go-lucky but occasionally violent
Bunch capable of minor Feats of reality
bending that allowed them to perform all
manner of Tricks they live on a diet of
mostly sugar and need to be milked
regularly clown milk is an invaluable
substance here at the circus as it's the
secret ingredient of the famous black
cotton candy which by the way is free
with admission it causes the brain to
produce high levels of Serotonin meaning
that when you eat it you're primed to
have a great time be careful though raw
concentrated clown milk is not for human
consumption though the clowns love to
drink it even a small amount can cause a
human to go into cardiac arrest due to
an overload of Happiness the sound of
calliope music also goes a long way to
helping people truly get the most out of
their visit to home and follow circus of
the disquieting the calliope is
self-playing and requires rolls of
perforated paper to be loaded into it so
that I can play a variety of
pre-programmed pieces of music each
piece produces a different psychological
effect on visitors who have consumed
their cotton candy the skater's waltz
will make them accept whatever they see
at the circus no matter how weird has
nothing out of the ordinary wonderful
for making sure nobody blabs about their
experience to a certain pesky Foundation
officer of the year makes them less
likely to perceive an event as unlawful
we use that one when we suspect the cops
are closing in Hell hail the gang's all
here his
visible to congregate at the big top for
showtime and American Patrol causes
those who have eaten their cotton candy
to seek out those who haven't in order
to strongly encourage them to have some
what do you mean you lost your dog is
one that gets played after hours when
it's time to get the clowns ready for
milking now that you have an idea of the
history and how things work around the
circus it's time for the tour the circus
is made up of a series of tents and
trailers as well as a Midway with
standard rides and games that you might
find at any circus outside the big top
where shows are performed once a day
there's also the den of freaks and the
hull of humans extraordinaire the den of
freaks is home to Fantastic acts like
slogo and Eliza the living head
Sluggo is a man whose eyes are on stalks
like those of a slug and he can bend
those stalks into any shape he wishes he
can even use them to create the shapes
of human faces Eliza the living head is
a woman whose head lives independently
of her body which is safely kept in
storage even without her body she can
speak and sing and often answers
questions from the audience the Hall of
humans extraordinaire is home to
performers who lack physical anomalies
but otherwise display otherworldly
talents like the amazing Zoltan a
fortune teller and Alchemist who Fuller
picked up at a place called The utterly
Bazaar the Hall of humans extraordinaire
also used to be home to icky the clown
back when she was still Veronica the
magician the recent lineup has changed
quite a bit thanks mainly to the
activities of the circus's constant
enemy you guessed it the SCP Foundation
or as they are better known to the
stable of interdimensional clowns as the
Miss SCP Foundation the foundation does
not appear to be a fan of circus folk
and many of the former acts are now in
their containment for example Madame
razarta and her amazing Palm Reader also
known as
scp-1884-a and
scp-1884-b Madame reserto was a blind
Albanian woman in her 60s who was born
without hands she shared a psychic link
with a creature named Luana who was a
large shapeless entity made up of 932
hands 929 of these hands appear to be
those of an old woman and chair Madame
razarta's DNA but the remaining three
hands seem to be from a male caucasian
adolescent an adult Hispanic female and
a Bengal tiger through her psychic link
Luana acted as Madame roserta's eyes
feeling its surroundings to provide her
with a mental map Fuller attempted to
buy the two of them when they were eight
years old but when the their parents
refused he sent many to whisk them away
under the cover of
darknesserta's act involved sending
Luana to fuel the faces of audience
members and then trying to describe
their appearance based on what Luana
felt the Act was a hit but Maran resorts
are claimed to have been horribly abused
during her time with Hermann Fuller
the two of them escaped while on tour
and were picked up by old SCP while
trying to rent a hotel room in the UAE
then this virtuosa also known as
scp-1860 virtuoso was once a book of
sheet music that was transfigured by
Hermann Fuller into one of the circus's
original acts it's a tall thin humanoid
being encased in a densely woven
paper-based material that stretches like
nylon or spandex it constantly drips
black ink ink which it has a telekinetic
control over it uses the ink to create
the shapes of musical notes which float
around it while it sings virtuoso can
sing in multiple voices at once across
different vocal ranges and constantly
performs aryas and show tunes for
whoever is listening it was recovered
from underneath a burnt down Shack at a
Fairground where the circus had been set
up earlier in containment virtuoso still
sings but translations from Italian
reveal that the lyrics of the Arya as
its singing have been changed to reflect
its own situation some of these
translated lyrics include one day I'll
tell you of my creation and life within
the circus born from the ringmaster is
breed another act the circus dearly
misses is motor mouth also known as
scp-2094 he was one of the rare human
clowns born in New York City in the late
70s from birth he displayed a
supernatural level of flexibility in his
lower jaw and as he Grew Older he
discovered that he could swallow large
objects and store them in a kind of
pocket Dimension until he needed them
again unlike Madame rosata he went with
Manny willingly as even at eight years
old he knew that his alcoholic mother
didn't care if he lived or died
motormouth took to the circus like a
fish to water and Grew From a shy child
into a very talented talkative and
highly charismatic adult he was a
juggler first and foremost who would
catch pins balls and knives in his mouth
as part of his routine but the name Moto
mouth came later in his career when he
let a Stunt Driver drive a car off a
ramp and down his throat however as
great an act he was a conflict arose
between him and many over Manny's
questionable methods of sourcing new
acts many found out that motor mouth had
been helping some of the anomalous kids
that many brought in to get back to
their families and as punishment for his
insubordination he was locked in a box
and left behind at the end of a Japanese
tour the box was marked for Essie
because many thought being put in
containment was the best punishment he
could think of with how strange and
unusual attacks are and how it always
seems to pop in and out of new locations
at strange and unpredictable times you
might wonder if the circus has any
Sinister motives well the truth is
though sometimes the ax can be a little
gruesome the methods of acquiring new
Talent are a little unorthodox and the
clowns a little out of control they're
only goal is to entertain in that
respect they're no better or worse than
any other circus so we hope you've
enjoyed your visit make sure to stick
around for the show and don't forget to
take your complimentary serving of
cotton candy because there's nothing
quite like a day at the circus
especially one like Herman follows very
few people would enjoy getting eaten by
a bear in the woods that would
undeniably be an extremely unpleasant
thing to happen to anyone heck it's
certainly enough to put a damper on an
otherwise fun weekend of camping but the
one consolation of undergoing such a
tragedy is that you at least know nature
is taking its course after all bears
live in the woods and if you decide to
enter their Turf there's an Unwritten
agreement that you'll just accept the
consequences if a bear decides it
doesn't want your company it's another
thing entirely if a bear eats you in
your bedroom in the middle of Suburbia
miles away from any nearby Forest that's
the unfortunate fate that befell little
Tommy Ellis his parents heard the
bellowing Roar of a bear upstairs the
floorboards creaking under its sudden
weight what was happening up there they
ran upstairs following the sounds of the
Roars and Tommy's horrible screams but
by the time they reached the bedroom it
was already too late the room was empty
torn apart from within and as a 600
pound grizzly bear crawled its way out
of the destroyed bedroom window Tommy
Ellis was never seen again to Tommy's
parents before they were given amnestic
treatment by agents of the SCP
Foundation it was a freakish one-off
tragedy but to those very same
Foundation agents it was just another
instance in a series of deaths so
strange and random that only some kind
of anomalous serial killer could be
behind it two months earlier in a nearby
town a family had undergone a Savage
attack from a full-size male silverback
gorilla the huge and heavily territorial
animal tore the house apart and beat
anyone who tried to stop it into a pulp
much like a bear attack being killed by
an aggressive gorilla in the wild isn't
that strange but being murdered by a
gorilla in the suburbs of Cincinnati is
definitely a cause for foundation
intervention however the gorilla killer
was long gone before any foundation
agents were able to intervene at first
it was assumed that they were dealing
with some kind of animal SCP but as more
grisly murders occurred it began to
paint a better picture of what exactly
was happening here next a family was
found dead after what had seemed to be a
brutal attack with an edged weapon but
this was no mere knife all the evidence
pointed to the weapon being a sword
neighbors interviewed by the foundation
about the attack before their amnestic
treatment reported hearing a frightening
Ruckus coming from the house next door
including a deep male voice saying I
have a power much like He-Man from the
popular toy and animation franchise this
reminded them of another recent murder
case where the killer also reportedly
used a sword though this time more
likely a Japanese Katana than a European
broadsword and was heard yelling
Cowabunga as they left the scene as the
bodies racked up the evidence kept
piling on a young girl was traumatized
by a naked man suddenly appearing in her
bedroom this would be horrible enough
but there were a few strange details he
was handsome athletic had bright blonde
hair and no genitals in fact he matched
the exact description of a child's Ken
doll and the thing that finally tied
this whole bizarre case together was an
entire family who was found to have been
killed by electrocution despite all
being in different rooms of the house at
their time of death and showing no
evidence of having being moved
post-mortem but the family's youngest
Stephen had a number of Pokemon cards
and action figures in his room
prominently featuring the franchise's
most well-known creature Pikachu this
shape-shifting rampaging killer was
caught not long afterwards when a
full-sized Pony suddenly manifested in
the home of another Suburban family
thankfully causing no fatalities this
time and galloped off into the woods
seeing as the foundation was already
keeping a close watch on the area to
make sure they caught any more strange
activity they were able to quickly
engage with and capture this strange
entity it was then sedated and sent back
into containment at the iconic site 19.
the creature is now known as
scp-137 so you're probably wondering
what exactly is happening here what are
the anomalous traits of scp-137 that
appear to express themselves in such
random and violent ways while it may
seem that 137's abilities are as diverse
as they are dangerous it actually only
has one very simple anomalous power it
possesses the toys of children and
transforms them them into their real
life equivalent a teddy bear became an
actual bear a stuffed gorilla became an
actual gorilla toys of He-Man and a
member of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles became murderous sword wheelers
and Pikachu became a wild animal with
powerful electrical abilities the SCP
doesn't appear to be inherently violent
either its level of aggression appears
to be in the eye of the beholder as the
attributes of the toys possessed by
scp-137 are defined by what a child
perceives about said toy for example a
pretend gun becomes a real one capable
of firing real bullets toys of dangerous
animals become equally deadly in their
real scp-137 counterpart Warriors and
soldiers become powerful killing
machines however this works both ways
adorable or harmless characters remain
equally adorable and harmless when
scp-137 possesses them it seems as
though the entity that possesses these
toys doesn't even have a consciousness
it only takes up the mental attributes
of its hosts incidentally this was
actually a crucial factor in devising
the proper containment method for
scp-137 within site 19 through testing
the foundation discovered that scp-137's
anomalous range is at least 250 meters
with a possible upper limit of 500
meters in order to keep the creature in
a consistent and harmless form the
foundation forbids any unauthorized toy
from being placed within the 500 meter
radius of scp-137 essentially the
foundation is boxed scp-137 into a
corner meaning that any toy placed
within its anomalous proximity is its
only option in this case the foundation
is locked as cp-137 into a form of a
wholesome princess doll identifying
itself as Princess Blossom when asked
about its identity in this form the
creature seems to have no awareness
whatsoever of its anomalous nature
scp-137 truly believes it is Princess
Blossom while occupying this form
repeatedly asking interviewing
researchers whether they're her prince
finally coming to save her from this
prison sadly for 137 her prince will
never come but perhaps she'll spend
every day looking at her own cell door
and hoping being physically incapable of
knowing any better but of course you're
not here to engage with the heady
existential realities of a shape and
personality shifting anomaly like any
reasonable person in this situation of
course you want to hear about the
experiment logs and find out just how
far this entity's ability to anomalously
take the forms of living toys can
stretch and don't worry we won't
disappoint you on that one either
scp-137 has some of the most insane
testing logs we've ever seen and we're
going to share them with you right now
the last one is a real doozy first over
eager researchers made the terrible
decision to introduce a toy plane into
the testing chamber with scp-137 how
could this possibly go wrong right right
well here's how the toy plane was
possessed by scp-137 which transformed
into a full-sized F-16 jet this jet then
attempted to fly off while inside the
testing chamber resulting in it flying
into the side of the chamber and
exploding causing a massive amount of
damage to Foundation property whenever
one of scp-137's toy hosts is destroyed
it returns to being a toy in this case
after the smoke cleared a small cluster
of broken plastic was laying on the
floor the researchers were then
forbidden from testing any toys with jet
engines or missiles but they didn't tell
them anything about toy race cars it
seemed these researchers really were
children at heart they were amazed when
the toy car turned into a full-size
Ferrari then plowed into the wall at
high speeds exploding vehicle tests were
suspended after this the next test was
actually kind of an accident an
attending agent had an amusing little
keyring shaped like an alligator when
entering the 2 150 meter range of
scp-137 you can probably guessed what
happened next because the key ring was
technically close enough to a toy
scp-137 took it over and transformed it
into a six meter long saltwater
crocodile it then lashed out attacking
and devouring nearby researchers 14 were
dead by the time Foundation security
officers managed to safely enter the
scene and terminate the crocodile at
that point searches were intensified for
all Personnel intended on working in
scp-137's 500 meter danger zone next an
action figure of an American Soldier
complete with a toy rifle what do you
think happened next if you're guessing
that this toy became a violent full-size
soldier that then went on to murder a
number of foundation employees before
being taken out by several Foundation
agents then you can take any prize from
the middle shelf just make sure you
don't bring your prize too close to
scp-137 or disaster could strike again
after this a toy police officer was
possessed by a cp-137 he began by
searching the testing facility for perps
and encouraging the researchers to stay
away from drugs this seemed almost
Charming to begin with until he pulled
out his gun and murdered two researchers
claiming they were criminals he
handcuffed a third before finally being
terminated by Foundation security
officers after this researchers on the
scp-137 project decided to Veer away
from testing on violent or dangerous
toys and instead brought in a stuffed
panda the sweetest and cuddliest of all
bears everyone agreed that this would be
a pleasant change when scp-137
transformed into one of the big adorable
beasts one researcher Overjoyed at the
presence of the panda accepted a hug
from it the panda hugged far harder than
anticipated breaking three of the
researchers ribs it was terminated by
Foundation security officers soon
afterwards it turned out that the
anomalous effects of scp-137 also
applied to non-sentient toys for example
a box filled with Lego blocks became
real terracotta bricks and construction
materials and a yoyo even when placed on
a hook on the wall with nobody nearby
continued to perform sick yo-yo tricks
with Reckless abandon the penultimate
test performed on scp-137 involved an
action figure of a character known as Dr
selenium advertised as the smartest man
on earth however when scp-137
transformed this into a real-life Dr
selenium the foundation discovered that
scp-137 couldn't actually imitate more
ephemeral qualities like incredible
intelligence this Dr selenium clone
simply walked around constantly talking
about how intelligent he was rather than
actually demonstrating that intelligence
he was probably the kind of guy who
comments First on YouTube videos and
finally the strangest test of all the
foundation constantly needs to worry
about moles and double crossers in their
midst they have tests to figure out the
presence of double agents working for
groups of Interest like the chaos
Insurgency or the Serpent's hand but one
group that they didn't have tests for
were Bronies adult male fans of the
cartoon My Little Pony based on the
popular toy series and it just so
happened that one of the researchers on
the scp-137 case was indeed a brony
that's why he snuck a doll if the Purple
Pony Twilight Sparkle into the testing
chamber causing scp-137 to possess it
and turn into the real thing he engaged
in a somewhat flirtatious conversation
with the talking pony leading to the
pony offering to take the researcher
back to her castle so they could hang
out after the testing session ended the
researcher was removed from the project
and then reprimanded by superiors for
using an anomaly to fulfill his personal
interests but working at the foundation
is an incredibly hard job with the risk
of death lurking around every corner so
who can really blame a guy for wanting
to hang out with his favorite cartoon
character between sessions with his 096
and 682. hey there Thrill Seekers are
you
are you crazy are you ready to get
to get all the little excitement in your
life you're the kind of stone cold solid
gold bad dude whose idea of a relaxing
afternoon is a staring contest with
SCP-173 and you're so tough you're gonna
make the peanut blink first you're the
kind of person who'd punch scp-682 and
make him apologize for grazing your fist
you wouldn't even back down from the
Scarlet King himself making the monarch
of ultimate dispersei that's pretty cool
man respect but if you want a genuine
Thrill Ride something that'll really put
hair on your chest you need to get your
butt on a truly hardcore roller coaster
what two chicken afraid of a little
emotion sickness or something or maybe
you've been freaked out by some of the
so-called horrifying accidents that
happened on roller coasters like the
1972 Big Dipper disaster or the 1986
Fantasyland Mindbender catastrophe get
real when has a little Dev scared anyone
at the SCP Foundation and besides
nothing is more awesome than an extreme
roller coaster and believe us any other
roller coaster will feel like Kitty
stuff compared to the absolute Beast
that we're gonna tell you about today if
you're a roller coaster novice maybe you
should try something like the takabisha
over in the Fuji Q Highland theme park
in Japan this baby boasts a 121 degree
drop famous for making people fall out
of their seats or maybe you want to try
something like Yukon Striker over in
Canada this Widowmaker of a coaster has
floorless seats a 360 degree flip four
inversions and a 75 meter drop that's a
little too tame for your taste if you're
feeling really Brave you can hop on the
Kingda Ka over in the New Jersey Six
Flags theme park you'll get a super fast
90 degree climb followed by a bone
stripping 139 meter drop a 129-foot
camel hump and a 270 degree spiral
that'll give you a healthy dose of
vitamin G-Force why are we telling you
all about this because compared to
scp-2183
all those coasters are like riding a
tricycle with stabilizers in your mom's
backyard there's no coaster more
powerful more thrilling and more
adrenaline pumping than
scp-2183 let's take a look at some of
the specs you can find this bad boy in
an undisclosed location somewhere in
Idaho this ride is so hardcore the
killjoys over at the SCP Foundation
don't want you to ride it but if the
lame-o's over the foundation out their
way nobody would be having any fun am I
right look at how they put the kibosh on
the Carnival of Horrors or as they call
it
scp-823 anyone who wants to go on one of
those rides will just submit the
business end of a foundation sniper
rifle and think about all the kids
who've been deprived of the awesome
childhood experience of craglewood Park
AKA
scp-2571 because the foundation Party
Poopers decided to Reign on everybody's
parade it's safe to say that if the
foundation wants to keep you away from
it you're gonna have a dope time with it
and the scp-2183 roller coaster is no
exception they have the whole park
blocked off and patrolled by at least
four security guards at any given time
people who see this piece in action are
given class F amnestics and they've
spared no expense in suppressing
anything about this coaster to end all
coasters in the media but trust us
getting a ride on this thing is totally
more than worth getting on the SCP
foundation's bad side that's right this
killer coaster has a max height of 37.2
meters and a max speed of almost 90
kilometers per hour you can't drive that
fast anywhere but the Autobahn over in
Germany sure it may technically be
unfinished but this bad boy still has a
physical track length of
798.8 meters you're probably wondering
why we said physical there right that's
because when it comes to scp-2183 the
real ride starts when the track comes to
an end baby when the ride starts to
Rolling it blasts down the normal tracks
like a bullet but when the track ends
and the carts fire off they don't fall
no way the carts keep speeding midair
continuing on the intended track from
the roller Coaster's initial badass
blueprints but that doesn't mean this
ride does everything by the books
scp-2183 is a ride that knows how to
party there's never any predicting the
exact ride length because every time the
carts fire off the uncompleted section
of track they take a totally different
path back to the start that makes
scp-2183 officially the most
unpredictable roller coaster in the
entire world the shortest recorded
length of the non-physical section of
track is 1080 meters that's almost
double the length of the physical track
and the maximum length of the
non-physical portion of the track has
been
5460 meters which is over twice the
length of the nagashima spa land Steel
Dragon 2000 the longest roller coaster
in the world but we know what you
Adrenaline Junkies are thinking it ain't
just the length of gets a major buff
it's also the heightened speed top
recorded Heights on the mid-air tracks
have been up to 100 meters making it the
fifth tallest roller coaster in the
world and speeds have reached a face
melting 180 kilometers an hour making it
the fourth fastest roller coaster in the
world but maybe like Shania Twain that
don't impress you much we get it you're
probably thinking fifth tallest fourth
fastest I thought you said this coaster
was truly hardcore SCP explained but
like a good coaster that's just because
we haven't hit you with the big twist
yet that twist being everything we just
told you only applies to when the carts
are empty when someone is actually on
this absolute monster of a roller
coaster it starts to do things you
wouldn't believe for you to really
understand just how awful rails crazy
this train can go we've got to tell you
about
d-93730 also known as the rider when the
writer woke up that morning neither he
nor the founder station researchers
handling him knew he was going to become
a legend as far as d-classes go this guy
was actually pretty lucky seeing that
he'd been convicted of one of the less
severe crimes that constitute d-class
Duty he was actually part of a release
program allowing him to eventually exit
the foundation alive and return to a
normal life after he'd been involved in
a certain number of studies it seemed
like a pretty fair trade however this
was a real pearls before swine's
situation any true coaster head would
relish the opportunity to take a Joyride
on scp-2183 it'd be the greatest honor
of their lives but for the writer all it
was was a source of sweaty palms and an
increased heart rate
talk about weak sauce am I right he had
no idea he was in for the ride of his
life in what would be both the first and
last human test of
scp-2183 they sat him down on one of the
carts strapped and buckled him in with
the safety bar and got that baby rolling
when the ride began the carts took the
normal path down the physical portion of
the track but as expected things got
crazy when the carts hit the anomalous
portion though nobody expected just how
crazy this ride would get least of all
our lucky little Rider himself if he
could still talk I'm sure he would have
changed his tune by now the writer's car
detached from the rest during the
mid-air portion and took a sharp right
going off on its own adventure around
the rest of the abandoned Park everybody
knew this was going to be something
special because even the foundation
squares had never seen a cart act like
this before it looped around the whole
place several times before whizzing
through the park like a cruise missile
weaving between rides stalls and
concession stands with ease it was
traveling blink and you'll miss it fast
this thing wasn't just white knuckle
intense it was broken knuckle intense
the rest of the carts returned to the
starting point again and came to a stop
but the rider wasn't getting off that
easy there's a reason we call scp-2183
the most intense roller coaster in this
crazy world of ours the card containing
the writer went AWOL heading north out
of the park at high speeds putting it on
a disastrous Collision Course with a
nearby Town well disastrous if you work
for the SCP Foundation totally awesome
for the rest of us the thing about a
ride on scp-2183 is that you really get
your money's worth when people nicknamed
this thing the ride never ends they
don't just do that for fun this ride
literally never ends over the first few
weeks of the rider's ride the foundation
just tried to suppress news of sightings
from spreading multiple people around
the nearest Idaho towns reported seeing
a Flying Roller Coaster cart zipping
around the sky thankfully for the kill
joys of the world that kind kind of
thing is easily written off as a trick
of the mind but this didn't stop the
writer's epic Thrill Ride from tearing
it up all across Idaho over the next few
months this party train really hit the
road metaphorically speaking of course
this card constantly remained 120 to 150
meters above the ground and kept
traveling at consistent speeds of over
200 kilometers an hour that makes it
roughly tied for the second fastest
roller coaster in the world the people
lucky enough to spot this bad boy in
action reported that they heard a
panicked terrifying screaming coming
from inside the card as it passed that's
how you know that the rider was having a
hell of a time in there real shame that
anyone who spotted it got a big old dose
of Class A amnestics from the killjoy
Brigade speaking of those squares the
SCP Foundation tried multiple times to
stop the ride and save the rider from
this awesome experience they sent in
helicopters and lowered ladders down to
him but the rider perhaps finally
appreciating what a gift he was given
here kept his arms fastened to his sides
his face forced into a permanent Grimace
nobody knew how he could still be alive
despite having no food or water in all
this time we can only guess it's because
scp-2183 is just that awesome anytime
these Foundation dweebs try to get near
the card it immediately undertook
evasive maneuvers and got the hell out
of there nobody could bring this
ultimate ride to an end in the end the
SCP Foundation proved they could take
being anti-fun to straight up military
proportions they approved firing a
missile at this piece of coaster dream
Tech hoping to finally bring its
awesomeness to an end after making a
valiant effort to avoid them the missile
eventually struck the cart they thought
the rider inside was dead but the cart
kept flying for another four years
before finally crashing 34 kilometers
from the rest of the ride relatively
unscathed probably after crashing into
one of those beefy Idaho pigeons and as
the foundation would soon find out the
writer was still around 2 do he just
wasn't in the card anymore nope he was
suspended in the air in a seated
position
124 meters above the crash cards we call
him the rider cause he's still riding to
this very day and if anyone comes within
a 50 meter radius of him in any
direction he'll just fly away until he's
alone again we don't know about you but
we think the Riders whole permanent
flying situation isn't a horrific
Purgatory of eternal torment if he's
alive under his comatose state it's
actually the ultimate ride and really
what more could you want out of life
right sometimes people working on the
site see him sitting in the cars often
only for a split second he's one with
the coaster now total Nirvana like we
said before kids the ride never ends now
go check out a sea snails fantasy
scp-1867 a gentleman an scp-1594 Miss
Jay's Wizkid Schoolhouse for more
interesting safe class scps totally
radical